foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happens
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
[Music]
mike check mic check one two
foreign
how's everybody doing tonight
or this morning for those of you uh who
listen from the UK
into the wee hours of the morning
oh man hold on I think the camera's
gotten
dude I'm out of breath right now because
so my son I I mentioned before how he
he's just getting into fortnite he loves
it we play together a lot
and uh he asked for V bucks for
Christmas so he got like
20 V buck card you know
and so he he's also really into Marvel
so he's just been waiting
for the right skin to come through
and tonight they just like uploaded
all the Marvel stuff all the Marvel
stuff so many Marvel guys in there
and so he and my four-year-old just like
had a moment freaking out
going crazy
yeah no the tree's still there it's
still there but for some reason the
whole the whole camera has like shifted
off screen just just slightly so I'm
gonna try to uh
let's see it's not letting me load it at
all hold up we're gonna try and control
alt delete here
which might be a bad thing
it might be a bad thing we'll see
all right hopefully it doesn't shut down
the whole stream
foreign
still there
still there all right I think we're
still there nice
Johnny what's up man retro hope you and
the family had a blessed holiday yes sir
yes sir
good to hear from me man yeah we did
indeed hope you guys did too
I I took this whole week off of work so
I'm off this whole week my wife works
unfortunately she works three days in a
row so the days are kind of they're a
little bit draining but
you know you love it at the same time
you get to geek out over Marvel fortnite
skins
add mode activated indeed now my
youngest son my four-year-old he loves
he loves the Spider-Man bad guys like
Green Goblin and Venom oh top of his
list
top of his list
and so both of those are back too but
man those fortnite skins they're
expensive
I mean I guess that's what happens with
a free game right but
they are not cheap so I'm like okay you
pick one and my four-year-old doesn't
play so I have to pick the skin that he
wants and I play with that one
so I think he I think he wants me to do
Green Goblin though
all right let's see here I need to close
out all of these little tasks right here
dude looking at my computer probably
should have restarted apparently
all right you know what let's get some
uh
let's get some Hogwarts Vibes going here
instead how about this right here
how about this right here for the music
there we go
[Music]
there we go by the way let's see we had
Elwyn with five gifteds and I think
see you guys gift so quickly like back
to back I think we had Ravenclaw Tyrell
in there too
Elwyn with five gifted memberships
member of House wreck and tour Elwyn
thank you so much and now thanks to
elwin's generosity
uh let's see oh wait I was like wait the
real life newt that's Ellen I didn't
know you added that to YouTube as well
that's awesome so devil Blom vaulty
volte what's up fuzzy welcome back fuzzy
one of our winners from our Christmas
stream a few days ago uh gravity's reach
and big evil 52 just got a gifted
membership from Elle and congratulations
folks congratulations you are now
officially members of house wreck and
tour and then I know I saw some from
Ravenclaw Tyrell too and it's just like
they I think they came in so quickly it
didn't pop up
but Ravenclaw Tyrell thank you as well
my friend cynics renewed their
membership cynics how's it going my
friend welcome to house tracking tour
good to see you here and then one shot
subscribe to the channel thank you for
subscribing to the channel one shot
all right let's see if we can get the uh
[Music]
clearly seeing all of these tasks that
needed to be ended I probably should
have restarted my computer
before
going live here all right now we closed
all those out my camera's still working
that's a good sign
all right now let's see if we can get
the camera software perfect there it is
and let's hit position one there we go
tree is back
everything's in order now guys
everything's in order
Debbie first time you've been able to
make it to a live nice well welcome
Debbie good to have you here good to
have you
how's everybody doing yeah now I see you
Ravenclaw Terrell's five gifted
memberships thank you so much Ravenclaw
Tyrell don't know why it didn't actually
pop up on screen and then I guess before
we got started we had lowercase Logan
C.W Evans renewing their membership at
house wrecking tour thank you guys so
much
thank you all very much for your support
hope everybody had a wonderful holiday
and now as we look forward to the new
year
but yeah man I uh
taking some time this week to get some
more videos ready
I'm trying to decide what the next one's
gonna be you guys have any
anything you're really wanting to see
like in terms of video I think I know
what the next one's gonna be but you
guys might be able to help me prepare
for the next one because I kind of feel
like the news is slowing down a bit at
least for you know I I would expect a
lot of the devs right now or on holiday
break and probably won't be back until
you know a few days into the new year
and then from there I mean the game's
officially gold on next-gen systems so I
would guess they're just gonna be as far
as like the dev side goes they're gonna
be you know last minute fixing the bugs
for that first big patch that will hit
and then also you know getting the uh
the last gen versions ready
then once those are out they'll probably
move on to the switch and everything
but yeah I mean it's it's crazy guys
it's crazy
like how close we are at this point once
January hits I mean we're pretty close
to be one month out now on the marketing
side on the marketing side things are
you know ramping up to a to a big time
level so this is when we will start to
see I'm assuming we're going to start to
see web ads popping up all across I mean
maybe on YouTube You're Gonna See web
ads on video game websites probably some
TV commercials too we don't know yet but
man when that first commercial drops you
know we'll be breaking that down
it'll it'll be geared towards you know a
mass audience so it may just be stuff
we've already seen
and then what else possibly a winter
ASMR how are you
I'm trying to think of like within we
got about a month left so it's like what
do we have time left for you know
as far as the marketing side goes how
are you now ravenclaws Tyrell started
popping there we go so let's see who got
elwyn's gifted oh no we already read
through Ellens now let's read through
Raven called tyrells welcome So Raven
called Tyrell we had uh Paula
oh man and Anderson andresage kucharski
Paradox gaming Andreas congratulations
and welcome to house wreck and Tour all
of you
I need to get my hammer back down Thor's
hammer
Dustin quizzed what is up my friend
welcome back Dustin with another Super
Chat
Dustin thank you so much for all the
love and support potential video talking
about a feature that hasn't been shown
yet but may or may hope to be in the
game outside of quiddish and gobstones
wait talking about a feature that hasn't
been shown yet but may or that I okay I
gotcha something that that we don't know
about yet but I'm hoping could still be
in the game outside of quiz and
gobstones oh interesting
I'm sure they're keeping some things
under wraps
to like for the final game I'm sure
they're not going to show everything
but yeah like
here lately they've just been I mean
especially this last showcase really
just wowed me quite a bit
wowed me quite a bit honestly
no surprise I love the Gryffindor
Gryffindor fireplace and music the best
here
okay let's see actually let's get a poll
going let's get a poll going then we'll
say hello to everyone in the chat sorry
I had this like I had this plan for how
I wanted the stream to go tonight and
then unfortunately my wife was running
late so I'm like well
stream's gonna be a bit late
and then the whole fortnite Marvel thing
happened and my kids just lost their
mind so we had to geek over that geek
out over that for a bit
but yeah so I really want to try to get
into the combat tonight
if you remember last time uh not on the
Christmas stream but on the our regular
Tuesday stream I said I want to try and
get through the Showcase like breaking
it down well we made it through that
first little section the like free roam
section we made it through that much and
that was it
that was it
[Music]
let's see tabby cat gaming with a super
chat as well got my streaming stuff
ready super excited for February excited
to see everyone's gameplay nice
see uh are you going to be streaming on
YouTube or twitch tabby cat
and then let's see I saw another thing a
one month from Casey welcome back Casey
happy to have found this community
you're all so friendly I'm very
appreciative of how nice you all are
hope you all had a happy holidays thank
you Casey yes good to have you here
Casey
yeah so I'm actually rocking
dude if you guys follow me on Twitter
and or Instagram you already saw
Mrs raconteur crushed it with the gifts
this year this is one of my gifts right
here got the Gryffindor beanie and then
got got a retro hoodie from the Retro
wreck into her shop
and also I didn't wear it tonight but I
got one one of the um like the Weasley
sweaters
I don't know why I didn't think of this
before but it just oh man ravenclaws
sorry you guys are
your song's really loud let me turn that
down a bit
I was like dude I need one of those
Weasley sweaters with the r
fits perfectly for retro right
she got it for me as a Christmas present
dude top tier Christmas gift giving by
Mrs raconteur this year
so yeah man I was super excited about
that
super excited for that and then we had
dream and plays games with a super chat
as well what are your thoughts on
getting some kind of story trailer
sometime right before launch
in terms of I guess what I liked okay
I'll answer I'll answer both of them for
you what I like to see one and do I
think we'll get one I think we'll get
something else on story but I don't
think it's gonna be
like I feel like when we did that live
stream with um Alex podcast now it was
like you know expect to go a bunch of
other Hogwarts Legacy content creators
as well I feel like they were all
wanting a little bit more on story than
I was
personally I just I don't really need
much else on the story I don't wanna I
don't want them to give away too much
and I don't think they will however to
answer your question I do think we'll
get a little something else on story
because they still need we're all hyped
we're all very aware of the game but
they do still need to reach that mass
audience you know and so I could see I
could see a story trade I could see the
TV commercial
foreign if they do a 30 second ad you
know they're probably
have at least a few story elements in
there
and then they'll want to highlight the
combat a little bit highlight the
exploration highlight the hippogriff
flying that sort of thing
so yeah I'll say we get I'll say we get
a small story trailer at some point yeah
but they can't give away too much
Harry Potter fans are just we're so
averse to spoilers
uh let's see dark lord Aeron yo another
one of our winners of the Christmas
giveaway dark lord Aeron with a super
chat hey retro hope you're doing well
did you catch Chandler's comment on
Reddit clarifying some mechanic concerns
people had related combat I did Dark
Lord Aeron yes thank you for bringing
that back up I actually was thinking
about if
thinking about if we have enough time
you guys because you know how we can get
off track a little bit but if we have
enough time possibly pulling up that
tonight because tonight my goal is to go
through combat
let's go through that whole combat
section
um possibly even some of the IGN footage
without
the commentary I want to do oh man see
there's so much I want to do it with the
commentary because you need to get you
need to get what the devs are saying
about it
but then there's some stuff you pick up
on in the no commentary footage that you
can't hear in that one certain spells
that they hadn't even I guess
technically hadn't even confirmed yet
hadn't even confirmed it yet
and then a noisy boy with another Super
Chat as well noisy boy thank you so much
for your support and Super Chat thought
the next showcase if any would be for
the story and classmates
maybe I think that's what James said
he'd like to see and several others said
that as well I could see that
but then I could also see them doing
like one more that is like hogsmead or
a taste of you know something outside of
Hogwarts that's not just the open open
air because if you think about it the
first showcase
I feel like that was sort of our
introduction to the classmates not so
much on the story side though but it did
introduce us to a variety of different
classmates
but yeah we'll see we'll see I mean I
feel like I feel like the clock is
ticking on the Showcase if they're gonna
do another one they probably have
already filmed it would be my guess
probably I've already filmed it if they
do have another one planned
I hope they do I'd love I'd love to see
I'd love to see one more like maybe
timed a week or so before launch
I think that'd be pretty hype and then
tabby cat gaming with another Super Chat
thank you again tabby cat YouTube will
have my first stream soon super nervous
and excited well good luck good luck
tabby cat yeah I'm uh
still trying to decide on launch plans I
officially put in my request for work
because I just I wanted to make sure
it's like I want to make sure the game
doesn't get any kind of delay so I
didn't want to request off months ago so
I waited and I request off I think like
the first
three days that week
it's like the game hits early on the
seventh so I requested off like the
sixth seventh and eighth I believe
but yeah I mean I have no idea like what
WB is planning in terms of a review
rollout
if people are going to be getting early
codes or not I don't know I don't know
but I mean those types of things would
start happening
you would think early to mid-January
right early to mid-January
and they did speaking of marketing they
did have a um
oh who was it I forgot the name
they did have someone Weston McKinney
they had uh he actually tweeted out this
was sponsored by WB
all right hold up hold up let me let me
uh here's what we'll do
here's what we'll do we will um
I'm gonna shout out everyone in the chat
and then we will jump into the news jump
into the latest news uh Vol de Garber
the Super Chat as well thank you
voldegar for the three dollar Super Chat
love Harry Potter don't like secrets of
Dumbledore yeah those uh
I enjoyed the first one I thought the
first one was solid second one was eh
and third one was kind of okay
I expected a lot more that's for sure
that is for sure I expected a lot more
all right let's see here oh my goodness
we already have had so many Chatters
thank you guys for all the support
and I think we've already hit
I believe we already hit 100 likes too
we do a random Harry Potter oh yes we're
already well packed 117 likes okay
so we got a shout out then we gotta do a
quote random quote from the Harry Potter
series
I think what's better than like because
when I've been doing the quote quiz what
I've been doing is just like going
online and searching out specific quotes
but last time I just pulled up the books
on my Kindle and picked a picked a
random quote I think that's almost
better
I think that is better
all right let's see here who do we have
hanging out tonight all right I don't
want just top chat I want live chat I
want everybody all right now let's look
at all the participants okay starting us
off here this is in alphabetical order
we've got ether a mod both members of
house wreck and tour there uh alte
welcome
b-i-q-u-e beak
member of House wreck and tour chill
chili Neato 1994. thank you for being
here dark lord Aeron member of House
wreck and tour Darth ominous and Geek
Squad what's up D Squad uh also I see
Debbie Robbins there as well uh devrel
devilblom Dr Sherman what's up Dr
sherbet Draco all four of those right
there house tracking tour members uh we
got dream and plays games Dustin and
Elwyn members of Palace Dragon tour
Fallen Shinobi oh man oh man then we've
got let's see we've got fuzzy Jake high
IQ Warrior J Rossi Jaber Jenny all
channel members right there thank you
guys so much for the support then we got
Jeremiah
and then another oh here we go we got
another long list of uh channel members
here okay here we go we got Jesse Casey
Kratos raptor85 what a great name by the
way Chris huffampoff welcome back Chris
Christie Jean Dyer is here in the house
tonight Lauren d as well then we got
Levi Maze We got lurk in the shadows
magic Klaus Magicka Michael Sullivan
those three right there are members of
house wrecking tour Mr cold
dude I've been freezing the past several
days Mr cold would have been a very good
very good nickname for me the past few
days uh Niraj is here Nico the real life
Chief warlock how's it going Nico
welcome Channel member there uh then we
got Nicholas Olson we got Neil Harrison
in the house Channel member uh Nevaeh
Nivea
Nokes peaceful chaos and then we've got
pineapple Sam radar Ravenclaw Tyrell
Robo Panda members of house raconteur
there uh rock you take Forte welcome to
the stream thank you for being here
Shadow guided and Sharon Cruz welcome
back to regulars and two members of
house wreck into a right there uh then
we got Shondell Sinjin soap
marverez marvers Mar man no wait soap
Man Rivers
welcome we got Tater we got the Potter
Legacy TJ bro tmac b Tom Snipes member
of House Dragon tour right there trippy
Moon voldegaard
volte and then
someone who is here and a member of
House Trek into her but it looks like
they have a symbol as their name it
looks like a bee
a Bitcoin maybe I don't know but thank
you for being here and hanging out
Noob what is up my friend Noob jumping
in here with the Super Chat as well
guys Noob regular member regular
supporter always here
on our Christmas giveaway the very first
name that we drew the very first name
that we drew man
oh I love that and it cracked me up so
much
cracked me up so much hope you got the
uh gift card Noob I didn't see like on
all the gift cards when you do them
through Amazon it'll say like hey
someone received it I didn't get it from
you Noob I hope you got the gift card I
hope you got it let me know if something
didn't work and come through what's up
dude just popping in to say hi and to
remind everyone
to stay hydrated yes indeed yes indeed
we got you we got you noob
a fresh can here of Coke Zero just a
regular Coke Zero I'm running low on the
on the Cherry Cokes they've been hard to
find lately
been hard to find lately
Dr sherbet with a super chat as well and
eat well
there you go I mean you are a doctor
after all right
you are are you are you actually a
doctor Dr sherbet
I don't know if I've ever asked you that
don't know if I've ever asked you but
hey just your name I mean I I would
trust Dr sherbet you know
Dr sherbet saying to eat well Noob
saying to stay hydrated hey those are
two messages I can get behind
I can get behind good question right I
don't know if I've ever asked that don't
know if I've ever asked Dr sherbet
JP drinking a regular Coca-Cola not zero
the weather okay uh for me it's been
it's it's fine now but we did have
for us like all you Canadians you guys
are you're Built For This
you're built for these negative
temperatures and you guys know and I
mean literally your your homes are like
built in different ways but here like
man we've had all sorts of fortunately
not for us but pipes freezing and my
parents had a pipe freeze to where on I
think it was on Christmas day there
their AC went out or not I see their
their unit their AC unit but the uh so
then they didn't have any heat
but fortunately somebody was able to
come out and fix it that day so they
made sure to tip tip him very well
but yeah there's been all sorts of that
going on around here people's units just
going bad pipes bursting things freezing
but it got up above freezing today and
we're gonna be about freezing again
tomorrow so I think we're through
I think we're through the worst of it
now
yeah Nico we got to negative 12 with
freezing rain basically negative 40.
yeah we were we were at negative seven
Fahrenheit on
the day before Christmas
somewhere in there so one of those days
which for like that is unheard of I
can't tell you in my whole life I don't
think I've ever seen
negative temps like that
if it got below freezing that was really
cold for us
Christy your move got delayed because no
right yeah so
I'm from I was born in close to
Nashville and they had they were doing
like rolling blackouts so even the
Titans game on Sunday they were they
played Saturday it got pushed back an
hour because they were doing these
rolling blackouts across the city I mean
it's just yeah
work had to close because the pipes Rose
minus 25 in Colorado
yeah it's just been crazy across the us
right now it's been crazy
minus 15 Celsius in the UK not long ago
oh my goodness Shadow guided
yeah the wind is rough too
the wind is rough too all right well if
I missed you guys
um I am uh I'm all the way at the bottom
of the chat now
but for those of you who who popped in a
little late we got started a little late
so you haven't missed much you haven't
missed much thank you all so much for
being here let's go ahead and get into
the latest news
I may have not changed my Christmas
scene back yet we'll find out here in a
moment
oh I did I did change it good okay
okay I did change it I couldn't remember
if I changed it back or not we do still
have the Christmas lights you know kind
of the our the rule around our house is
like you keep all the lights up the
trees stay up until New Year like once
New Year's is here then we start taking
everything down so for our next live
stream all the little lights you'll see
we'll probably have those I'll have
those turned off the tree will probably
have the tree down as well so I thought
for one more night we would keep like
the we'll keep the green and red keep
the Christmas tree in the background
same says radar same for Lauren D yeah
yeah same for Tom Snipes as well
retro says Christmas is over no not yet
not yet
James staying up till February nice
oh that's a good idea Jenny stay up
until January 5th
for the 12 days Adam says New Year's is
the rule uh voldegaard with another
Super Chat sorry I missed that one a
couple minutes ago how long of a Time
skip for sequel you think Albus
so I think I think each game would be
one year voldegaard which
I'm actually questioning the date of
when we start the game
and I don't know if it's 1890 anymore
I don't think I've talked about that on
this stream we talked about that with
James and all of those uh other Hogwarts
YouTubers when we were on with podcasts
now
just real quick just just the real quick
version of this guys so you remember the
chudley Cannons poster which we're all
like wait the dates don't line up there
correctly Troy Levitt former Hogwarts
Legacy developer worked on the game he
saw it too he actually tweeted about it
and said he was gonna reach out to Avila
and say hey I think they made an error
here
well then like a few weeks later he's
like
sorry guys I should have never said
anything Avalanche knows what they're
doing and then we saw the poster again
so the poster date is correct so now I'm
wondering like
that date in the very first reveal
trailer did they change that date and is
the game does it not start in 1890 and
we've just been using that daily profit
date all this time could you imagine
I mean it's just a one-year difference
but still like then that throws all the
stuff with Albus changes right
so if we start in 1890 my expectation
has always been
they would like to do multiple games and
do like your final three years at
Hogwarts
so we know we start as a fifth year do
five six and seven and they would be
like a trilogy
but that's I mean that's like 100
speculation you know
100 speculation I just think that's what
they would love to do
Dustin with another Super Chat Dustin
thank you so much for all the love and
support in case y'all weren't here for
the last stream if you pre-ordered a
digital copy of the game it may have
been refunded because of the change
release dates here's a reminder to
everyone to check on your computer
status indeed yeah and especially with
PlayStation I think PlayStation sent
people emails
if you like pre-ordered for the last gen
versions because of the changes with the
release date and all that
I saw seemed like a lot of people were
saying hey I got refunded I got an email
but then I still saw a few people saying
like hey I didn't get anything so
definitely a good reminder to check up
on the uh the status though for sure
especially if you um especially if yours
was one of the ones that's been affected
by the delay
for sure
and then right off
um the back of Dustin with the donation
high IQ warrior with another Super Chat
anyone gonna try modding your systems
with a Hogwarts Legacy theme with
PlayStation skins custom controllers oh
so excited for this game almost one
month away
I have seen some pretty cool Concepts
over on the Harry Potter game subreddit
yeah there's been some very cool
Concepts
I don't personally have any any plans
for that I'm usually kind of a very I
don't really customize a lot of my
electronics I just like the
straightforward you know controllers
but I have seen some really some really
cool ones
Chris been a member of House recenter
for one month so grateful to you retro
and all my retro besties
um got vid
vid oh
gotcha I was like wait vid video sorry
to hear that Chris there's nothing I'd
rather do and quarantine than be here
price of Health Care I suppose oh man
hopefully you're you're not feeling too
rough Chris
hopefully you're not feeling too rough
[Music]
and then Dylan with a super chat what is
up my friend Dylan the real life
surveillor of activity with a five
dollar Super Chat
yo says Dylan and hashtag replay Squad
oh my goodness you got
you guys aren't even letting me
we can't even get to the segments man
we can't even get to the segments
[Music]
Christy with another Super Chat the real
life Madame Malkin
if you guys are like what the heck are
these names so my moderators here
uh here on the channel and on the
Discord came up with the idea of giving
themselves like
nicknames that are
I don't want to give away too much
because they not they may not want all
of this being out there but they're
Loosely based on
some aspects of their personality in the
real world and bringing it over to a
Wizarding World nickname so we have
Dylan the real life serve surveiller of
activity Christy the real life Madame
Malkin I think Elwyn was the the
real-life newt scamander
which Elwyn has talked about publicly so
I know Ellen wouldn't mind me sharing
elwin is a dog trainer you guys so that
one very fitting and then I saw Nico in
here earlier Nico had a had one as well
so if you guys are like where did these
come from there you go creative
moderator group we have but Christy
hello thank you for the Super Chat as
well I hope I hope everything uh I saw
your comment about the move getting
delayed
because of the weather so hopefully
that'll be able to
happen soon enough
but okay before we get into our quote
real quick
so
soccer player right here Weston McKinney
tweeted this is just this just like
dropped out of nowhere a few days before
Christmas December 22nd
here we'll just let's just go ahead and
watch it yo so I feel like stuff like
this this is the start of the big ad
campaign like the mass the mass campaign
you know
all right so let's uh put a pause on
this for a minute make sure our sound is
up
what's up guys I'm Wesley McKinney and
this is my Hogwarts Legacy fan story
[Applause]
I've been a fan of the Wizarding World
I'd say probably since I was six years
old my first first set of books for one
of my grandmas and ever since then I so
where is this at I think what what they
like at his house
the fact that it was he's about to get
to play the game like so into fantasies
if you haven't seen that was always
someone that was really big into like
you know thinking oh I really want to be
able to fly one day or like oh I wish I
could be invisible or I wish I could you
know you know do a magic trick or
something and and like it was just kind
of like an escape like you kind of felt
like you were in it you you have a big I
guess it's at the end it's like I know
they show them playing the game
my my goal celebration is you know one
waiting and you know like I'm catch a
spell and I want to have something that
you know symbolize me but also oh that's
cool it's been easy for people to
connect with
yo let's go no no don't do it to me no
God I got defeated
so that's footage I am on fire and so is
he
that's a little different that hat right
there what now what now
[Music]
that's a little different
you guys may have saw a little bit of it
but you have not seen all of it just
wait I could tell you for sure what you
expected of the game is definitely gonna
exceed it so just wait
hmm interesting interesting so yeah this
was
this was on what did I say December 22nd
and so I was wondering like okay we're
gonna get like a couple more of these
celebs you know in the coming days and
no that that's been the only one so far
that I've seen so we shall remain
we shall remain on watch to see if we
get any more of these and if they show
any other additional footage so that had
a little bit of new stuff but things
like this I feel like are the start of
the big yo what's up guys I feel like
those are the start of the big uh the
big ad campaigns that sort of thing
foreign
State
um so if it's for PS4 oh I see chat chat
got you there
Omar yeah so the current gen versions
like PS5
Xbox series s and X
uh those are all still releasing the
same time but if you're on PS4
here you go right here
if you're on PS4 or Xbox One it's been
bumped to April 4th
and the Nintendo switch is July 25th
[Music]
Olivia Thompson finally made my first
live stream yo let's go that always
excites me when I hear people say that
it's like somebody who's been excited
about seeing some of our videos and then
wants to actually make it to a live
stream
so welcome thank you so much for being
here
[Music]
no Tom no so the the last gen versions
got delayed so PS4 and Xbox One
those had a delay
so if you're next gen or no no if your
current gen or PC you're fine
but if you're if you were planning to
play it on PS4 or Xbox One it's it's
gonna be April now that's why we were
talking about the uh we had the Super
Chat a moment ago from Dustin who was
saying check your pre-order yeah if you
pre-ordered digitally for either of
these platform well even if you did
physical for either of these platforms
definitely want to check up on on that
and you know decide decide what you want
to do right like if you want to keep it
especially in the case of the digital
Deluxe because I mean now you're
essentially
you don't get the you don't get the
Early Access anymore for those two
oh you got a PS5 you're good okay yeah
yeah
all right so
we talked about that then the other
thing I wanted to talk about
[Music]
let's see right
so we had these we already talked about
these but it was the um the combat
so let's go ahead and hop into the
latest gameplay showcase
now you guys know
if you're regular's here at Ground speed
so on our last stream we we're like
let's go through this whole thing
well three hour stream goes by and we
made it to about this point right here
this is about where we made it
so we're gonna dive back in here oh wait
you know what before I do that though
and and we're just looking and put up a
poll question Hogwarts in the distance
it's just absolutely beautiful it's part
of what I love what's up Jay Rossi
welcome
or on the Broom getting the PS5 the next
few days nice things that you can see in
the distance and that's one of my I I
still can't get over like no matter I
play this so much but I still I still
can't get over the fact yeah chat kept
derailing me because we were we were
staring at bodies of water to look at
what creatures were Professor showing up
on the mini map I can just fly my hip it
happened several times like as the
character's flying front doors all right
let's see poll question poll question
two Greenhouse start a poll that's all I
had dude what was the pull I had a poll
question I lost it oh and then I
remember the other thing we forgot to do
I'm speechless right we do have a
hundred likes so we're we got to do a
last time we gave you kind of a an intro
to combat this time we're gonna really
go uh yeah this is gonna work a lot
better I'm just gonna pick a random book
random Potter book from my Kindle all
right Andrew's got us in the Forbidden
Forest which is where the dark arts
battle arena is
part of the deluxe and digital deluxe
edition
battle arena is actually uh part of the
world that's integrated into the world
so your experience is more immersive
than just choosing an option from from
the main menu of the game or something
like that
exactly there are many reasons to go to
the Forbidden Forest but uh he's also
wearing the uh dark arts cosmetic set
and uh here he's pulling out the
thestral which is part of that dark ice
pack from the deluxe and digital deluxe
edition so we're going full full these
are too obvious oh that's good that's
why I'm going down but I like these are
too obvious it is a great place to show
off
um really combat in a big way because it
unlocks some interesting abilities for
you and and allows you to to really play
around with uh combat in a deep way and
is this like the only Arena like this in
the game where you can like practice it
yeah so in the in the base game we have
two combat Arenas normally hold on
and you gotta go to a different channels
these are too obvious for a difficult
combat Challenge fight through multiple
waves in order to uh earn a a different
cosmetic for your character and add that
to your collection
um in the case of the that's no
different than the oh okay I got one I
got no that's also true uh the combat
Arena but uh but uh yeah one of the
things that we're excited about all
right so if you guys are new here
whenever we hit 100 likes on the stream
we do a random bit of trivia random bit
of quote trivia from the Harry Potter
series so I've picked a random quote you
get one point for getting the character
an additional point if you get the book
right most of the time people get the
character it's the book that people
usually have a little bit of trouble
with don't cheat don't cheat that ruins
all the fun
ruins all the fun what do you win you
might ask well you know just the ever
undying admiration of your of your
fellow members of house wrecking tour
here
and that's it nothing more nothing less
all right here we go so
quote
there have been another couple of
dementor attacks blank announced
and they found Igor kirkorov's body in a
shack up north
the dark mark had been set over it well
frankly I'm surprised he stayed alive
for even a year after deserting the
Death Eaters
Sirius brother regulus only managed a
few days as far as I can remember
end quote pretty long quote right there
pretty long quote we'll read it one more
time
there have been another couple of
dementor attacks blank announced
and they found Igor kakarov's body in a
shack up north the dark mark had been
set over it well frankly I'm surprised
surprised he stayed alive for even a
year after deserting the Death Eaters
sirius's brother regulus only managed a
few days as far as I can remember
all right chat let's see if you can do
it
let's put a little music on while we
wait
[Music]
get a little music going while we wait
here
all right I'm scrolling to the first
answer I see
all right we got Lupine we got Lupine
book Seven we got fudge Snape Order of
the Phoenix uh Remus Half Blood Prince
book four Lupine Order of the Phoenix
fudge book three
uh let's see who else do we have Arthur
Weasley book five
fudge book six Bill sounds like Hermione
Lupine book six need to reread the books
again says ZZ shirer Tom says want to
say Lupine McGonagall book six question
mark Lupine book Seven Loop and five
book six Moody lot of Lupine so far uh
book four fudge Lupine five Lupine five
Lupine Order of the Phoenix Lupine Mad
Eye Moody book five winky Remus Lupine
book six Lupine book five Lupine book
six book five Ron
Dumbledore book six
Loop and book five Mad Eye 6 Arthur Six
this is hard yeah that one was a tough
one
but we had several people get it we
added several people get it the correct
answer is indeed Remus Lupine and it is
from Harry Potter and the Half Blood
Prince
chapter six draco's detour
one of the uh first couple first quotes
in that chapter
foreign
I wanted to be different Mr Moe
well-chosen quote thank you ZZ it was
Trevor nope not Trevor
not our boy Trevor
yeah nice job a lot of people got that
and pretty quick too
letting my dog out here
[Music]
if she's already eaten and she gets mad
if I don't let her in but if she hasn't
eaten yet
she wants back out so she can go eat
Mr cold I'm gonna start crying in the
corner like winky the question was so
hard
no
yeah so I think this works out better
than trying to go to online and find a
quote I like doing this better
at first I was in a later chapter of
Half Blood Prince and it was just like
it was the chapter when they're going to
Slughorn well not later just
actually wait no that was it was an
earlier chapter yeah when they're going
to slughorns with Dumbledore and it was
like all Harry and Dumbledore quotes
like these are too obvious
these are too obvious
listen to the audiobooks when driving
falling asleep best thing ever done for
insomnia
nice
yeah Luna is my dog's name yep she's
made an appearance on stream a couple
times before
but she uh she is off to to eat her
dinner right now
wish winky had been in the films right
all right let's see let's dive into the
combat now
I do I've been really looking forward to
this you come in please so let me
actually before we do this though I want
to see how long so it goes from 13
minutes
two
to about 20
21 or so so this is literally like eight
minutes of footage surely we can get
through this and then get through the
IGN footage as well
print abilities so uh the unforgivable
curses all right so I've made a couple
videos about the combat already
particularly the unforgivable curses and
I'm still seeing a bunch of comments of
people saying like I can't believe they
locked this behind the paywall
so just for clarification for everyone
here just for clarification on this
I think you guys here all know this but
if you see anybody in the comments
saying this now you'll know to be able
to clarify this the dark arts as Alan
says here the curses themselves are not
behind any kind of paywall
they are in the main game
what is not in the core game is this
Arena that they're about to go in here
when you can just like go crazy uh with
the dark arts there are two other Arenas
in the game
but the third one here is part of the
dark arts uh pack or whatever which you
can you can buy as an add-on even if you
buy the standard version of the game
or if you buy the deluxe or the
collectors it's included with that so
just a point of clarification there
because I'm still seeing so many people
confused by that
argued with people about this subject
Johnny
yeah it's like I I keep seeing this
coming over and over and I I re-watched
that section of my video I'm like wait
did I did I describe this incorrectly or
something no I I'm pretty clear if
people watch the videos all the way
through they will definitely hear
everything so just to be clear this
whole area here is indeed part of the
dark arts pack but the um
the curses themselves are not
so just a point of clarification access
to those and each of the combat Arenas
Noob with another Super Chat
and we also had JB subscribing as well
as Ashley subscribing thank you for the
subscriptions guys Noob I'm all alone in
this stream Alicia isn't here to cause
chaos what what's Alicia is at least
you're busy tonight
people not paying attention dark lord I
know right
people just immediately want to jump to
uh
you know some sort of like
conspiracy or something
it's all they the dark arts are all paid
DLC are you kidding me
okay now first I want to talk about some
additional icons
this icon right here
matches the statue obviously so we see
it on the mini map here in the bottom
left we see it right here in front of
the statue and then it's clearly a
depiction of that statue right there so
I wonder if all of the Arenas if the
other two Arenas share the same icon as
well now notice another thing I'm
catching over here on the left
a spider web with all sorts of little
red arrows
all sorts of arrows over here
around that spider web so I think we can
be pretty sure that's an opportunity
challenge fights through multiple waves
in order to uh earn a all right so for
people who missed it let's listen to
Alan let's listen to it in Alan's words
here
so he can explain the arena two combat
Arenas normally that and so everyone has
access to those and each of the combat
AR units are an opportunity to kind of
just go through a difficult combat
Challenge fight through multiple waves
in order to earn a a different cosmetic
for you so they're all combat challenges
you fight through different waves and
all of them and you earn different
Cosmetics well this one you earn I'm
guessing the dark arts set that we see
them wearing right here which is also
part of that dark arts pack
for your character and add that to your
collection in the case of the that's no
different than the dark arts battle
arena that's also true
of the combat Arena
wait what I want to hear him say that
again prince in the dark
character
in order to earn a a different cosmetic
character and add that to your
collection
um in the case of the that's no
different than the dark arts battle
arena the Leisure not are you for real
what
did they tweet about this
if you don't mind saying what uh what
country are you in please or not thank
you for the Super Chat by the way I was
so excited by your Super Chat that I
didn't even uh
I didn't even thank you for the Super
Chat I was just so excited by what you
actually said
hold up hold up surely they would have
tweeted that out right
no I don't see anything from them
oh my goodness I gotta look this up is
it on the Reddit or somewhere maybe
thing
oh you guys gotta let me know
hold on I'm waiting to see if Leisure
not responds in the chat here
believe it or not if you don't mind
saying which uh country you live in
got an ad on YouTube
United States on TBS oh my goodness what
all right I gotta look this up now
was it
I'm gonna I'm gonna pepper you with like
a hundred questions so just be prepared
um
was it 30 seconds was it anything new
did it show stuff we've already seen
oh man like there's nothing there's
nothing about it on
let me try Google
Hogwarts Legacy TV commercial
no I don't see anything
I'm not seeing anything but that's crazy
I was we were just talking about that
we were just talking about that Leisure
knot I was like I feel like it's about
time
for TV commercials and stuff like that
volte said they got an ad on YouTube
yeah usually that kind of stuff uh
serious people will I mean you'll see it
on
social media or somewhere I feel like
you saw it too Johnny what
I haven't seen it anywhere guys
search Hogwarts Legacy TV spot
in the last 40 minutes are you guys
trolling me right now
both of you saw it as well it wasn't
anything we haven't seen before the ad
oh gotcha
been seeing cable to ioko says I've been
seeing cable TV oh my goodness
so is it just like it's just stuff from
the trailers that they've kind of
reworked
I'll keep checking chat by the way but
we gotta move through this or I'm never
gonna make it through this
promise not a troll all the time says
Johnny it's on right now Comedy Central
I spoke it into existence like the jump
seeing ads non-stop on tick tock
rushed over here once you saw that's
crazy Leisure knot I don't know if you
were here for the beginning of the
stream we were literally just I was just
talking about that the combat around
that's crazy
okay that's actually a good poll
question I had another poll idea and I
forgot it so I saw you guys like where's
the poll
have
have you seen a commercial
yet for Hogwarts Legacy and this guys
this poll goes for TV or web so on
YouTube like YouTube ads have you seen
commercials there have you seen
commercials on TV have you seen it at
the movies wherever
wherever poll question is up
because I personally have not
I have not
spammed on Tick Tock see I'm not
surprised by The Tick Tock and YouTube
commercials but usually I feel like
I feel like when the TV commercials hit
that's kind of like a big deal and
people start talking about it
all right I'm just waiting to see okay
ether says I've seen shortened at oh my
God you guys you guys gotta start
maybe I'm just out of the loop on this
one
usually people tag me and stuff like
this but then if it didn't show anything
new I guess you all were like okay it's
not that big of a deal
astral night welcome first time seeing
you live hey nice to see you here my
friend
wasn't there a Cinema One too Dr Sherman
oh man you guys are all just trolling
now you guys are all just trolling
uh Owen says I think the original poll
you want to do is asking people what
other video topic oh yeah
that that was probably it elwin thank
you
you see anyone on TV take a video yes Mr
Moe please please please
like I feel like I could I could see
Chandler you wouldn't post that to the
main Hogwarts Legacy account I don't
know maybe you would
maybe you would but I could definitely
see Chandler posting like guys check out
our new ad spot airing now on
okay still seems like I'm definitely in
the majority most people have not seen
it
we got we're up to 96 votes in the poll
guys uh if you're just getting in let me
know vote in the poll have you seen a
commercial for Hogwarts I guess yet on
TV web anywhere have you seen one so far
because I had no idea I had no idea that
they had started showing these just yet
but I've seen enough people to say
enough people to say that they have that
I'm believing it pulling all the stuff
out of avalanche oh my goodness you guys
oh geez
in Norway it shows on YouTube
commercials nice
well that's great that's awesome dude I
had no idea
I had no idea all right so they're
getting ready to go into the arena here
fight waves of enemies in this battle
arena with the unforgivable curses Vada
cadaver imperio and crucio as well as
the blasting curse confringo in addition
to their unique and devastating effects
unforgivable curses break through all
Shield charms I hadn't thought about
this before
but I wonder if that is always
true of the unforgivables or is it only
true in this battle arena
because at first I thought oh that must
be always true for them but the way this
is worded I'm kind of wondering if they
only break the shields in this
particular Arena
because just listen to the way it sounds
in addition to their unique and
devastating effects unforgivable curses
breakthrough or maybe they always do I
don't know
I don't know
oh my gosh okay now I know you're
trolling Jake one of the things that
we're excited about in the dark arts
Battleground
is is you come in pre-loaded 15 seconds
easier to buy it nothing new in the
cinema unforgivable curses or something
everyone's going to have access to
through the base game and going to all
right guys okay listen to Alan again
guys listen everybody multiple curses
are something that everyone's gonna have
access to through the base game and
going to be able to earn one more time
the unforgivable curses are something
that everyone's going to have access to
through the base game and going to be
able to and one more for with closed
captioning on uh the unforgivable curses
are something that everyone's going to
have access to through the base game and
going to be able to earn and there we go
stop the national nightmare there it is
guys they're not locked behind anything
oh I'm just I know all you guys here
know that but it just you know sometimes
with the comments man
sometimes with with the YouTube comments
I'm just like
just just watch guys just watch it's
crazy how many like I've I have learned
there are a
I wouldn't say a large majority of
people but they're a fair number of
people who evidently just like comment
on YouTube videos without without
watching literally anything
it's like oh my goodness I just want to
comment on this thumbnail I want to
comment on this title and that's it
that's all they're interested in
commenting like that's literally what
your your question is what the whole
video answers so there you go
there you go
and they can make choices in order to
kind of like add that to their
repertoire and they can also commit to
that down with certain talents and
things like that that part's super
intriguing play the Dark Horse combat
Arena you actually have access to all
those things as kind of like a way to
test them all and so and I love that
they're doing it this too because they
know there are some of us who are at
least on a playthrough or two will want
to play like a no dark arts run so like
hey we know you're we know you want to
test them out though so here you go
we're gonna make this arena for you
where you can kind of just go crazy if
you don't want to learn them in the main
game it's a chance to kind of like tour
and play with the dark arts and decide
whether or not that is a path that you
kind of tested stop stop it everyone has
to say stop it it's for explore the dark
arts this is just kind of like a way of
previewing
allity there's he even said it again
listen listen
oh wait I just killed this great place
or explore the dark arts decision but
but yeah everyone has the same ability
to explore explore the dark arts this is
just kind of like a way of previewing
and again a great place for us to show
off combat in general uh so I think
we're gonna jump in here
and we start talking about uh everything
you're seeing on the screen all right
and then they just like immediately go
with the AK
just immediately to the AK
uh also the challenge over here hit a
Ranger with Stupify
[Music]
right away oh my God we're starting off
strong damn crucio oh my God and then
inferior yeah so that yo and you guys
can hear you'll notice right away like
when we well we'll watch the IGM one
after this and then you'll get we'll
talk more about the sound effects
all right so this cursed effect
that they just hit this dude with
imperio right here so you see the eyes
so if you remember back from the post on
Halloween they had the little kind of
like the imperio info card or whatever
and it said basically Imperial will turn
an enemy to fight for you
they take they're more resistant to
damage against other enemies so like
once they start attacking the guys
you're fighting then they're gonna start
getting hit with stuff too however
they're stronger but they're weaker to
the player
now something that Alan talked about in
this showcase when they have this little
green X they are also have a a cursed
status effect and anyone who has this
effect as he's about to explain here in
a bit they all share the damage so we
got this dude kind of over here off
screen to the right that you can't see
right now
the guy yeah the guy's screaming the
intense screams over here on the right
he's hit with crucio he also has a green
X and then so does the guy with imperio
right here you Savanna cadaver that
guy's health and then this spell that
they use right here that's so cool yeah
so that you'll you'll notice right away
like whenever you see red above the
player's head guys that is one that you
cannot deflect so see the red right
there many games have done this I'm
playing God of War right now so it's
it's really on my brain right now
um but like when you see a red attack
coming in God of War you you cannot
block that one so the only way is Dodge
I'm 99 sure that's a very similar
mechanic here because every time in this
trailer that we see the red the
character always Dodges so watch you're
gonna see them Dodge left here and then
hit the uh the guy up there on the ledge
with an accio so Akio is the bottom one
here
and then this is the little red one is
just like the basic shot so I think this
confirms I remember when they first
showed that basic shot I was like oh is
that just stupefy I think this confirms
that it is not stupefy because the
challenge does not get marked as
complete right here
I know right it's it's the little things
it's the little things guys
I was like man is that just stupefy no
it is just like a basic magic shot
probably like a flippindo or something
really so hit a Ranger with Stupify
doesn't pop there
I went from instant to zero and we
really are trying to honor them I'm
gonna go ahead and take off the closed
captions again because I want you guys
to see the uh when you see the combo
meter and stuff here
oh yeah was it a is that where they cast
AK I didn't even watch the spell you'll
know just right yeah look at that it
probably was Avada Kedavra
so you get the red indicator with Avada
Kedavra cannot deflect that one true to
the books good catch guys good catch
yeah so you can see the the the green
right there we Dodge out of the way
right away like when we use Avada
Kadabra went from a couple basic shots
and then what is that one right there
yeah so that you'll you'll notice right
away like when we cadaver that guy's how
far went from inside it's just like an
uh like a combo I guess a more powerful
basic shot because you don't see any of
these
go away
that right there is descendo the one
pointing down zero and we really are
trying to honor the way of all the more
basic shots even in some pretty extreme
okay now this one notice the difference
sorry guys I'm I know I'm kind of
geeking out I'm I'm so pumped about the
combat I'm so pumped about the combat
watching order the Phoenix right now
will be nice let's go last Marauder in
the house what is up my friend fellow
Hogwarts Legacy content creator there
guys
hope you're feeling better last Marauder
I I know after that big stream we all
did it was like everybody was Andy
somehow through the power of the
internet and he spread his illness to
several of you
kind of crazy
kind of crazy
gonna hop off Noob too much going on to
focus
wait you mean on stream there's too much
going on
or just in uh just in your in your real
world right now either way Noob thank
you for being here
have a good night
L when this is not gonna go well for me
I'm horrible at dodging in games
uh hopefully you can get really good at
uh protego then but then again the AKs
you know some things are not going to be
able to dodge
and then you got the R1 which we've seen
from the other trailer we know that's a
pug no
have a good one Casey have a good one
hit you too
Chris
oh yeah you were just yeah you were just
talking about that earlier
last Marauder good now caught the vid
back to full health oh that's good good
I'm glad glad you're back to full health
not good that you caught it in the first
place
white wolf after watching this gameplay
in the first one when you hit the fourth
basic shot a combo it looks like it's
almost a three times damage white wolf
that's a good good info drop right there
yeah so that R2 just that little basic
shot they were talking about that fourth
one it definitely looks a little bit
different but I think we can confirm
that it is not one of these over here
because of what we just saw and then
white wolf there saying that it does a
little bit of extra damage a little bit
of extra damage there
all right so what I want to say right
away oh look at that dude over there
with the imperio he's fighting for us
Nevada cadaver works in the game and
then see the yellow
so we're not even looking in their
Direction trying to honor the way Avada
cadaver works right there the yellow so
the yellow one this is also good to know
that you do not have to be facing their
direction or anything like that you can
immediately get triangles
you get the protego wait do we actually
take damage right there hold on hold on
we really are trying to what is that
furniture
or is that like the visual indicator
for potato situations
on earth away oh no we do get hit he
gets hit right here yeah look
it takes away a little bit of Health
I did not catch that the first time
um you'll notice that like the game even
in some pretty extreme so he was he was
a little late on the time
even in some pretty extreme situation he
tried it but it was too late I did not
pick up on that at all the first time
so yeah you see how that one right there
he took a little bit of damage
kippers with the Super Chat yo kippers
thank you so much for the support
coming in there with a 9.99 Super Chat
can't wait to be the most evil Ravenclaw
to ever ever exist oh my goodness the
ravenclaws evil ravenclaws man it could
be a dangerous dangerous thing
a very dangerous thing
lost the combo too right
oh yeah yeah the frame by frame yeah
yeah
yeah he used potato too late I did not
catch that the first time at all
oh you guys were saying they uh I think
you meant earlier that I saw I saw their
Twitter post earlier yeah
the stuff that we'd already seen
that's crazy though that he so he was
late with the protago all right now I
want to go and I want to see what on
Earth I want to see what this so this
guy gets up and then he oh man so this
that he hits him with right here
is defendo
which it's this red if you watch the uh
the footage without any commentary see
this is why I don't always do frame by
frame because it takes forever to get
back to the exact moment I'm looking for
all right let's just hit it a couple
times there
so you see like that like Little Slice
going through the air so that's this red
one right here sort of Slash you've got
going on
see if we can back it up enough to where
we uh
there you go
all right so he gets hit by the guy over
here somewhere takes a little bit of
damage he was late with the protego then
he's gonna cast this uh red one right
here which is defendo I'm actually going
to slow it down here and let's turn
there
audio off
oh that's so cool so you get the Little
Slice like right there with the findo
then he completely turns around okay now
he's got to focus on this guy
he's got to focus on that guy who hit
him in the back just moments ago
hits him with a basic shot and then oh
dude the uh the guy that we have in
Period over here
welcome pool Cube kinda High Jedi
welcome
and also Hannah how's it going guys
welcome
like the imperious oh wait let me scroll
back up guy complaining he was
manipulated oh can you can you hear that
if the uh
if I had the
footage without the commentary you might
be able to hear it in this one too but
so then he immediately starts hitting
this guy with the basic shot
gets him with another basic shot oh no
no no that was not a basic shot right
there that was definitely uh descendo so
yep you see that one go away right there
basic shot now oh no accio sorry I need
to I'm speaking too soon then there's a
basic shot
oh and then you're right the fourth one
does more damage
when you just do that basic shot back to
back to back to back
and what I love we're gonna see it here
in a second we finally got confirmation
of how how you're able to switch through
these so quickly
there he goes with the epugno right
there
hitting it with R1 smashing him right in
the face
all right let's bring Alan back here
some ways that we're probably talking
about kind of like watching still fun to
use and then there's see if you can hear
him deal with it's extreme power just
that it's still fun to use it I didn't
hear him that's the ways that we'll
probably talk about to an accio in the
basic shot then descendo I don't know if
there are things on the screen we've
completed questions
ah frustrated player how's it going dude
welcome thank you for being here hope we
can get eye patches and add scars after
the fact yeah because they said some
things will be locked and then some
things you'll be able to change after
the fact
I feel like eye patches probably yes
scars I I'm not so sure about that one
if we'll be able to add that one after
the fact
last Marauder the ancient magic gems
heal you slightly good catch like I feel
like yeah because he's definitely got a
little more Health now oh wait I wonder
if it automatically refills wave
to funding you build up as a way to kind
of deal with its extreme power just that
it's yep right there he just collected
good catch last Marauder and it almost
looked like it was sort of an auto
collect like he didn't really run over
deal with he just kind of runs in this
direction yeah and then it automatically
absorbs it there fun to use and then
there's some some ways that we'll
probably talk about to to so you can see
he's going with a lot of these
sort of I guess combos that they've made
up like he he does the accio you get him
brought up to you in the air then you
can hit him with a couple basic shots
then a descendo to adjust that but I
don't know I I don't know if there are
things on the screen questions
okay now we got goblins dropping in
loyalist Warriors so notice they never
they never got that challenge for
Stupify
they never got this challenge right here
for hitting a Ranger with Stupify now he
does say later Alan makes a comment
about if you hold triangle down so we
know triangle is the
is the way you cast
oh my gosh I'm getting out I'm getting
all the Spells confused now it's the way
you cast potato your Shield charm
if you just tap triangle I guess it's
just like a quick deflect if you hold
triangle he says that it will actually
fire a Stupify back at them
I wonder if that's the only way to cast
Stupify or if it's actually a slottable
one as well that you can do
whoa we got a lot of questions that I
missed
let's see I saw last Marauder's comment
uh yeah Leo quidditch feel is definitely
in the game but we don't know if we'll
really be able to how much we'll be able
to explore it
wonder how we will increase our health
yeah you know there will definitely be
like upgrades and stuff for that so I
wonder are the ancient magic gems
is that the only way you refill health
well no potions for sure there's going
to be potions
be a Slytherin and destroy everything in
your path dark wizard says you
manipulated me you'll answer for this
yeah we're gonna try and watch through
the other footage here in a second the
uh the unedited or not unedited the uh
no commentary ancient magic is almost
like part of their magical life force
uh you can gravity's reach
Oh you mean wait hold on let me read
that I really hope they let you name
pets just like you can name beasts oh so
you mean the ones that you're riding
around
I would think so right I mean if you can
name the ones in the room of requirement
surely you can name the ones that are
actually
you know going around and helping out
with your mission
does the player character say vodka
diver every time not every time volte
not every time
which a lot of people have been
wondering
you know come on it's not supposed to be
non-verbal but
that's one of those areas where I'm fine
with them taking Liberty on
because guys trust me it would get so
ridiculously annoying if every time they
say the incantation think about that if
every time you cast a spell like
especially in battle like this if they
if you heard them say the incantation
every time
I think that would get annoying maybe
there maybe there's like a hardcore mode
where they say it literally every time
uh just a little bit Jedi just a little
bit they had a dual sense trailer
several months back but it really didn't
reveal a whole lot
right last Marauder yeah yeah Stupify as
the counter attack
foreign
how long does the shield charm last I'm
guessing just like a couple like a
second or two I think it's supposed to
be like a quick time thing
how's it going Mr Park welcome
yeah Johnny Johnny gotta head out have a
wonderful stream got kid time now yes
indeed enjoy it Johnny I wonder if there
are d a combos to learn similar to like
in the dueling Club could do more damage
love that switching the spell diamond is
yes exactly dark lord Aeron which oddly
enough I froze it at just the right
moment here
I had been wondering
how are we going to be able to switch
between these so quickly because they
kind of touched on it in the Showcase
with James but they didn't touch on it
as much this time or after that they had
they didn't really dive into it more in
that one
but in this one we get to see when they
hold R2 this is the button prompt that
shows up
these buttons right here do not pop up
unless you're holding the R2 but now we
also see that the d-pad lights up down
here in the bottom right and so you can
basically map four different sets
you have four different sets of four so
you can have 16 total spells mapped to
your d-pad here
and then you can just very quickly swap
them out we see them do it a couple of
times here
TBS just showed it again Leisure knot
dude how have we missed this well I mean
you guys clearly haven't missed it but
but I have
chat still only say our poll guys 253
votes 71 percent have not seen a
commercial 29 have okay well
very interesting
Theta feta welcome how's it going
uh yes indeed in America
especially if one wants to cast it as
much as possible Right like if people
are just spamming
pretty sure the grab horn named Bruce is
the same one being written in the
Brazilian feature
maybe yeah I mean I don't see why not
like I feel like some of those character
some of those some of those characters
some of those creatures will be the same
ones
time how long it is between AK uses
timed it a couple of times it was
between 30 and 35 seconds seems way too
low Mr Mo says
right Jay Rossi right I mean wandless
magic is definitely a thing but should
we as a fifth year be capable of it
that's what people were kind of like
getting a little
come on now we shouldn't be we shouldn't
be allowed to do that
all right let's go forward a little bit
more here
think commercials are only showcasing on
channels ah interesting Reese
interesting
not one less wordless yeah yeah well one
less is the thing too
but yeah you were I guess you were
specifically talking about wordless
but even one less magic was a thing
which I guess was supposed to be even
more difficult
maybe the liquid luck helps with the
cool down yeah and then they also talk
about they talk about another question I
don't know if there are things on the
screen that you just have questions
about well like I see like little blue
these
from the enemies also before like that
sign well it's like so in the community
we call it the ancient just the ant the
Anvil that's hilarious size
we call it the ancient magic I love the
goblin attacks dude that this is clearly
that corruption so in the community we
call it those attacks I just love the
animation with that oh yeah in the game
so all right so he hits him with crucio
right there so now he is cursed he's
just gonna basically stay there so uh on
the development side and in player
facing oh it looks like you get
invincibility frames when you're in the
middle of a spell the community as a
student so uh
or did he just duck under it oh my
goodness like he leans forward right
when he swings
I don't know so I don't know if it's in
invincibility because you're in the
middle of this spell casting animation
or if it's because he just swings right
over you on the development side and in
player facing in the game we reference
that as your internet there's an
imperial oh it is ancient magic that is
yeah so as you're as you're another AKA
growing and you become exposed to some
of the secrets about your own kind of
history and your own there we go there's
a successful protego right there so get
ready there's the yellow and then the
deflection abilities and a Defender
unlocking new powers so one of those
Powers you'll see your own ability shoot
to blow up
I'm going to slow it down here
the CM fire off a spell does he shoot it
at the oh yeah
that's not confringo though
is it just a basic shot aimed at the
barrel
okay that I'm really curious about
so he finishes off the loyalist Warrior
so we see his health go to zero and then
I bet he just acts he just accidentally
casts another basic shot you're a wizard
and it hits either the Fire or the red
Barrel
and then just causes the huge explosion
everything just explodes
he shot the bonfire okay yeah I was like
he looks like he's aiming more in the
direction of the bonfire just was kind
of the basic shot there
uh welcome to the new Subs guys welcome
thank you for being here
personally like to protego in the state
of play reveal latest showcases the huge
bubble appears always when deflecting
lessens the impact of the wand
deflection animation I saw where did I
see that Reddit maybe I saw some people
talking about that or maybe in a comment
somewhere
bonfire is explosive too I mean I I
guess if you fire a basic shot at it
very close to one of these uh
Powers so one of those Powers
uh throughout the game uh that's an
ancient magic throw we call it that
allows okay big question about this guys
did they change a pug no
did they change a pug no because listen
to how Alan describes it here
we have all we've seen this as a pug no
and I mean it makes sense as a pug no it
behaves like a pug no so did Alan either
misspeak here or did they completely
change this I'm gonna put caption on too
so you and actually let's rewind a
little bit more so I want you guys I
want to make sure we hear this one
abilities
um you start unlocking new powers so one
of those Powers you'll see the R1 button
appearing uh throughout the game uh
that's an ancient magic throw we call it
that allows you to kind of like draw an
object to you and swing it at an enemy
um okay but whenever you see the R1 or
the L1 plus R1 appear so today is a pug
no gone
yo past 200 likes all right
we'll we'll do the impression here but
I'm I'm too into this right now uh
that's an instrument I'm just I'm geek
I'm nerding out guys let me nerd out
here for a bit I need your feedback I
need your feedback on this is a pug no
literally gone it's like did they
probably call it the one button
appearing uh throughout why would this
be an ancient magic ancient magic throw
recolor that allows you to kind of like
draw an object to you and swing it at an
enemy
um okay but whenever you see the R1 or
the L1 plus R1 up here over somebody's
head
um that's an ability to cast a very
devastating and Powerful uh Angel magic
spell nobody with any thoughts okay dark
lord Aeron a plug no wakes more way more
sense than an ancient magic throw like
surely he wouldn't I mean I can't
imagine Allen would misspeak about that
oh you know what we need to do though
you know what we need to do is we need
to watch or some of you can probably
tell me for any of you who have watched
the no commentary footage all the way
through
do we hear a pugno at all
do we hear a pug no at all always
figured a pugno was only used for
objects the cast or made themselves like
when Hermione made the birds
I don't know if that's a lore thing or
not I don't think so all right now you
guys go now we gotta go we gotta do some
digging now all right so Hogwarts Legacy
state of play
we gotta we gotta we gotta Circle wagon
here go all the way back
to this into Magic
and then we also with that question
we've got to now
let's look up the exact definition of a
pugno
all right so the epugno Jinx is a spell
that directs an object or an individual
to attack the victim right okay that's
what I was thinking Jinx will cause
conjured conjured creatures or other
movable objects oh interesting
this Jinx will cause conjured creatures
or other movable objects under the
control of the Caster to attack the
target
wait a second
all right I want to see it at HP lexicon
I want to read it from here now
oh
dude
maybe they did change it
maybe they thought maybe they decided
that it was an error
HP lexicon guys is my go-to when it
comes to the lore because they only like
the wiki is great too but the wiki like
anybody can can update here
a pugno is an incantation which causes
conjured creatures
under the control of the Caster to
attack the target
dude
Hermione used this set of a fly that
one's the one that everybody remembers
right
performed after the bird Conjuring charm
on wonder book of spells where the
incantation is called a jinx
doesn't say it anymore Luca
they changed it you guys
they changed it
all right so just so everybody's on the
same page
I think it's more toward the end when we
just start going crazy with all the
all the Spells
rescue them and restore them to Health
in the Room
Master spam missed it haven't I befriend
new allies journey across dude this one
see this one's so old now
this one's so old I forgotten where
everything is
how has no one pointed this out yet or
maybe they have and I just missed it
just like they changed well they didn't
change the chudley Cannons poster they
didn't change it
oh my gosh somebody help me please
oh wait is it is it in the first trailer
is it in the first trailer 643 oh
dark lord Aeron I was almost there thank
you dark lord Aeron let's go
and dark lord Aeron with the Super Chat
to get to give me a tip oh Ryan needed a
stream today thanks retro a Ryan
thank you for being here my friend
thank you for being here
okay so guys we have just stumbled upon
something I mean if you're like hardcore
into this game I think it's a pretty
pretty significant deal here
direct weapon strikes
okay clearly a pug no right there
right we all hear this
counter-attack there it is so a hundred
percent the R1 used to be a pug no we
see it in the other in the other uh spot
where they they do it on the uh that
sword from the knights the the knights
in the armor that come to life that
sword oh man I love that animation too
so this was 100 a hug no at one point
Mastery of The Shield charm allows you
to deflect ranged spells and direct
weapon strikes
now if you guys are just stumbling in
wondering why the heck is retro losing
his mind here
so in the most recent gameplay showcase
you know how R1 the little R1 we've
always been talking about that hey
that's a pug no that's a pug no that's a
pug no because we saw it right there in
the state of play watch this dude
you start unlocking new powers so one of
those Powers you'll see the R1 button
appearing throughout the game that's an
ancient magic throw we call it dude I
gotta make a video on this
um okay but maybe a short because the
vast majority of people will not care
about this the vast majority will not
care
like
Dustin oh my gosh okay ancient magic did
away
they ancient magic did
Nico just rewatched the IGN combat video
100 don't say it anywhere they did they
changed it you guys
now that kind of stuff though like
I kind of I applaud them for that dude
because they clearly they had it in as a
pug no the the effect of the spell is
exactly the same I think the only reason
they changed it is somebody stumbled
upon this
somebody somewhere
maybe it was Boston maybe their lore
Guru whoever was in charge I'm sure they
have a lot of people who like oversee
the lore and everything
they very likely stumbled upon this and
said hold up guys a pugno is only
supposed to be used
on incantations which causes conjured
creatures under the control of the
Caster to attack the target
Chris with the Super Chat thank you so
much Chris
I will I will I will tweet at James
right after the Stream
I will tweet at him and let him know
obliviate rewrite a pug no even the time
we see it Hermione uses it with the bird
she conjures right
yeah and I guess that's the only time we
actually see it right
in the books I'm pretty sure that's the
only time oh my dog wants back okay
she'll make an appearance
dude I forgot I'm going my earbuds
tonight this is a little more
comfortable than the big headset
sometimes
laughs
are you coming back
all right if you went back in you have
to say hi first
you have to say hi to everyone
dude we need a Luna emote
there you go
okay all right so Cameron's right here
you gotta look there's the camera all
right if you want to talk there you go
that's where you talk yep yep and then
our chat the chat is over here on this
side see the chat there they're talking
to you right now
they're saying hello
they're they're saying hi to you can you
say hi back let's see can we get can we
get get a little high there are you
tired of this now are you ready to go
what you done when she comes in here her
bed is over there in the corner
she just goes and uh and lays down there
yeah you stay by my side all day don't
you all day as soon as we put the kids
to bed she just like completely chills
out the rest of the day she knows that
she has to be she's like always on alert
always on alert watching out to that she
doesn't get ran over or something so all
right I'll let you down
I'll let you down they wanted to say
hello to you
and if you're wondering yeah she's named
Luna for for the reasons that you think
for the reason that you think
yeah Mr Moe ice Nico said he did the
same too she's going in your viberia
let's go dude
so yeah so someone I need to go back
whoever said the comment
dude an undercover Dev whoever said the
comment about isn't a pug no only used
for conjured creatures
that is an undercover Dev in the chat
I'm calling them out on it right now
right now
oh man okay so it's not a pugno anymore
guys which take that off our list of
spells or maybe maybe not right maybe a
pugno is still in the game
but we don't even know if
transfigurations in the game
we don't even know
sorry man I'm just like
this is like such a find such a random
find but
oh my goodness Chris that's I love that
idea naming my name My Fantastic Beasts
after my favorite YouTubers what beasts
do I want to be oh I love this well we
don't even know all the beasts yet right
we don't even know all the babies
I mean right now given the beasts that
we know about I would probably say
hmm
I would probably if
if there's any kind of flying creature
like dude if we could get a if we can
get a phoenix in the bavarium oh my gosh
that'd be so awesome
any kind of flying creature but of like
the confirmed creatures I guess I would
say probably a grab horn
probably a crab horn
no Draco it's a couple people in the
chat just said they went and watched the
IGN footage which
um has no commentary
and you do not hear it at all you do not
hear it
um okay but whenever you see the R1 I
can't believe we didn't talk about this
right away I remembered thinking oh
that's weird whenever he said it live
and I was reacting live
but then I just never Revisited it
because I was like oh maybe I
misunderstood him or something
because then he leads that which it
actually makes sense with the controls
they have set up for the L1 and R1
it makes total sense here because they
they tie it right in what he's about to
say now L1 plus r won't appear over
somebody's head up here over somebody's
head
um that's an ability to cast and this
this is something that a lot of people
have missed too I missed it myself my
first couple times
we were all asking okay what decides
whether they turn into a chicken or
whether they just get obliterated
Alan's about to tell you a very
devastating and Powerful ancient magic
spell to do a ton of damage against the
characters and the way that manifests
itself uh depends on the type of enemy
that you're fighting and you'll see it
do you hear it
the way that play it again listen change
your magic spell to do a ton of damage
against the characters and the way that
manifests itself uh depends on the type
of enemy that you're fighting the way
that manifests itself depends on the
type of enemies that you're fighting
Dustin with another Super Chat Dustin
with the crazy support in terms of the
super chats lately thank you so much
Dustin a pug no on the mannequins in the
haunted house maybe
I mean I think it would only be
anything that has been conjured but it
has to be conjured by you I mean if
they're sticking to the lore this much
then I think they would stick to this
under the control of the caster
creatures more specifically
creatures
conjured creatures under the control of
the caster
so mannequins I would probably say no
and you'll see a wide variety of enemies
in here that are pressuring the player
in different ways you'll notice oh wait
hold on so we get this one ancient magic
blast I mean this dude just like
combusts look at that just the explosion
forget about a kadavra man this is more
painful variety of enemies this is
ancient I mean look there's there's
nothing left of this man there is
nothing left of him fighting and you'll
see a wide variety of enemies in here
that are pressuring the player in
different ways you'll notice there's I
mean at least the vatic cadaver is just
like instant right bubble up under the
player as it's fighting that forcing to
move and there's different ways that we
want oh now that was a nicely timed
protego right there and there's the
message where we talk about Stupify
earlier so hold triangle Deering protego
to stun enemies with a Stupify
counter-attack the player as he's
fighting all right so Elwyn you said
you're bad at uh dodging maybe you'll
have to get really good at deflecting
then whenever you see the yellow watch
for the yellow around the player's head
here and there it is really more like a
gold
and that's a pretty quick timing too
clear as it's fighting that force him to
move and there's different ways that we
want really quick on the battlefield
that's actually so I guess they didn't
hold it down because I didn't see
anything like a Stupify forcing to move
and there's different ways that we want
the player to kind of move around on the
battlefield and that's actually a good
link to the intermagic leader in general
and the reason why I say that is because
furicio just goes right through the
shield here we've got another gold
you're doing different things in combat
you're portugaling and you dodged that
one abilities
there are different ways to get fat not
a pug no faster but one of the most
effective base ways to build up that
meter fast that way you can launch these
devastating attacks whenever you want to
is is to actually perform combos so you
see that combo here it's almost like
your your emotions are building up okay
you can attack someone but as the combo
meter builds up at some point you strike
someone and a piece of their magic kind
of falls out of them you'll see the blue
orbs in in the okay so he's talking
about the little orbs that we get to
build up your meter even further so one
way you build this up is by just doing
the combos then another way is by
collecting and there's something that
only you can see in in the narrative in
the world and it's another reason to
move around on the battlefield because
I mean they give big big jumps to that
ancient magic meter as we're playing
we're talking a lot about about spells
uh and Magic here but I think there's
another huge component of combat and
that is the the tools that you can bring
to combat as well to kind of uh dude I
don't think I'll use tools at all I'm
just going to be like all spells
Mr Mel been working on this for nine
years hey congratulations getting your
wife to read the books it took me a
while to get my convince well at the
time she was my girlfriend now my wife
but when she did she she enjoyed them
quite a bit
quite a bit
um
change the way you play and uh this is
the most recent showcase a lot about
what's going on with the wins on Howl
and so the the tools what you've seen so
far basically like a prior investment so
you can bring our Legacy let's go
is it is it a Rick Roll video
I'm kidding I'm kidding
all right let's go
oh my gosh you guys are not kidding
you guys are not kidding
thank you so much Potter Legacy all
right
quick side track here
quick Side Track apparently Hogwarts
Legacy commercials are officially
happening on air in the US right now
here we go
get some scenes in that uh so these were
a lot of these are from that first
trailer
the choices you make now with the final
Legacy
of Hogwarts
and this that's how you know it's for
sure new because you get the uh the
pre-order popping up after
a lot of this is from the first trailer
that's interesting they're using so much
of that I mean all that's from the very
first trailer
like I don't even think the uh he
doesn't even put our hat on
we see the uh
what we assume is the Deputy
headmistress Professor Weasley yeah so
that's from the first trailer that's
from the first trailer that's from the
first trailer
all this is from the very first trailer
yeah so very very quick
very very quick and then you get the
title screen and then you get the
pre-order now
yo thank you for the tag dude
thank you very much that is crazy
actually let me go ahead and uh
let me like that
thanks so much
I gotta retweet this too
several people in my chat
were saying they had seen
Hogwarts Legacy commercials and I didn't
believe them
one of them tagged me here though
and it looks like it's
actually happening
interesting that all of the footage
it's from the very first
reveal trailer
foreign
that's so cool
I don't know why they didn't show any
other footage though Logan what's up
dude
it's been great my friend it has been
great
all right well now all of you can vote
in that poll and say you have seen
you've seen the commercial if you were
here on stream I'm just going to go
ahead and end it now
31 had or 30 said yes they had before I
ended it and 69 no had not
channel will see this and have a new
commercial just jumping out tomorrow
right oh man
it's crazy guys because we were we were
talking about it but I guess they've
been airing for a while and I truth be
told I don't watch a lot of TV
I don't watch a lot of TV at all and on
YouTube I hadn't seen any I had not seen
any ads for it yet
all right so let's try and get through
this combat man I I we we've we've found
so much here we found so much cool
combat uh to essentially kind of help
you
um defeat enemies a lot quicker and more
efficiently so the window right there
which is red immediately breaks the
shields that you'll see here are like
the rock Skin Potion so that is
something that technology that covers
your skin in this like Rocky material
that uh reduces the incoming damage that
you're seeing all right there you go so
they use that right before the battle
with the mountain troll
level 20 on the mountain troll now
against big enemies hard-hitting enemies
like trolls not that they need the rock
potion because of what they're about to
cast right here
enemies of a higher level than you will
be harder to defeat not when you have AK
instant insta KO right there the troll
just collapsed from one another Luca
says the German commercial shows stuff
from the state of play interesting
uh obviously we have those uh that's an
ancient magic spell J Rossi and then
would you imagine we're about to see it
here shortly it's about having to
balance Avada Kadabra with a long
cooldown because obviously it's an
instant kill uh one thing that you could
do is potion and that will increase I'm
going to go back frame by frame so you
guys can see all of these potions right
here
so she called this one a focus potion
and that's the one that helps your yeah
right here reduces the drinker's spell
cooldown so it's not specific to one
spell reduces it for any spell and here
are the ingredients that you'll need
lace Wing flies flux weed stem dug bog
tongue
and then so you hold L1 to get this menu
to pop up pretty sure here we have
venomous tentacula right here and then
if we go back a little bit more I think
the one on the left over here is the
Cabbage obviously we have Mandrake here
and then pretty sure the at the top is
the wig and weld because obviously it's
an instant kill
you there
yeah so that's the Chinese chomping
cabbage cabbage formidable chopping
cabbages that when released attack
nearby enemies chomping cabbage seeds
can be purchased at dogweed and death
cap must be grown in medium or large
pots
and then we can see here this one looks
like another kind of whitish clear
potion this one's sort of purple this
one up here is red
ocean and that will increase
um how quickly your your cooldowns
regain right
there's just so much like oh dude I
thought I was wondering if that was
going to explode I wonder if there's if
he hits it just right if it will or if
it always just kind of works out what
the character is doing to the troll
right now like he's just bouncing around
around and then a challenge here hit a
troll with its own
and the troll makes him move around too
looks like and I love that our plants
are violent yes and so that's like when
we're talking about the almost the oh
wait did that have it I love that our
plants are violent yes and so yeah
venomous tentacula tenacious stentacula
that when deployed shoot acid at nearby
enemies venomous tentacular seeds can be
purchased at dogweed and death cap must
be grown in large pots that's like when
we're talking about things almost the
setup of the Arena you also have all
right oh no they did so we have things
like the venomous spectacular that you
could put down and it acts like getting
ready for another ancient magically that
is so cool this is like a truly like
huffle puffing way to approach the
battle yes no that was super important
to us so there were things like multiple
ways and so you can see there's there's
a ton of different things
once you can pull it out and it stuns
with like piercing cries enemies
another thing I want to call out uh that
we're seeing on the side of the screen
here is these these dueling Feats which
okay hold on
uh that one looks like they had a purple
shield and I think they're gonna cast
descendo which you can't really see it
too well because of the transition they
go from the little smaller screen to the
big screen here but it's this one right
here the hand pointing down
in a radius right another thing I want
to call out uh okay so yeah you do see
it over here there's dueling Feats which
I love because I love anything that
prompts me to play a game in a different
way a unique way I don't want to get
stuck in my style you know uh and and so
this is a way to if you guys so we've
got the ancient magic ready to go
now what I want to know is what happens
if you let this meter fill all the way
every time in the trailer we see them
cast an ancient magic spell it's with it
only halfway so is it a different spell
when you get all the way or is it just
you just get two of them
I don't know
not sure
I'll go for it all right here we go J
Rossi spells go for it but we also want
to okay so that one it looks a lot like
the chicken one but you never see the
chicken
so you just get this sort of like I
don't know this black smoke almost like
when Voldemort got
his met his end and the movies uh have
some things over here that may make you
now what's interesting is Alan said that
that whatever it cast is based on the
enemy so one of those other enemies we
saw him it just sort of like he combusts
with with flames just go everywhere if
you just want to blast people with
spells go for it but this guy I mean he
just very briefly we see his whole body
turn just like this charred almost a
burnt look to it watch it
oh that's
that's gosh we also want and then there
he's just gone uh he's just gone things
over here that may make you there's the
Anvil again there are certain potions or
block more or yeah we mentioned the
field guide challenges
um uh imagine a chicken only place they
feel good challenges this is the way
that the field guide's manifold
hilarious
and exactly to your point
um so we got this Ranger up here
using a little crossbow I just wanted a
way to encourage players to to explore
the different systems to help them
decide to just kind of practice with
them and explore what they want to be
because there really are so many
different ways that you can push talents
okay so we got hit with like petrificus
totalus right there I guess and explore
what they want to be because there
really are so many different ways that
you can push talents wait who who hits
us with this let's kind of practice with
them and explore I'm gonna slow it down
because I don't see where this
all right so we're focused on that one
over there there's a defendo fired off
at him and there we get a red okay so
somebody is
we try we try to use protego
oh I think we were a little too early
maybe on that one so yeah it was that
that guy over there we mistimed it so
now we have to mash Square to get out of
it
all right now they're good now they're
good
through your town so you can unlock this
kind of cursing mechanic that sort of
like links the face here he's talking
about the person Battlefield that way uh
as you get the as your person oh right
and so we have things like yeah I could
see that too Lily but if you curse
everyone before you insta kill this one
there's a couple different effects from
it for that kind of ultimate is it
unlockable
and so um
I think we got a chicken coming up now
defense against the dark arts character
things look at that but see here's what
I'm confused by that looks like the same
fantasies about being more of a deal oh
no it is a slightly different enemy the
other one had kind of like this
electricity on his wand but the the
character model looks very similar to
the guy who
turned into like the black smoke and
just evaporated
I want to watch this one in slow-mo this
is the chicken one
oh dude that's so funny so that's the
l1r1
another way that our ancient magic can
manifest right there
oh I think is that our only look at
confringo right there
if you guys can't tell I haven't done
this deep dive yet like that's why
that's why I'm so excited just just keep
taking out over all this combat I've
only watched it like I've watched it
through a couple times just normally but
I haven't done like this full breakdown
which is why I haven't made a video on
it just yet but that will happen
yeah so confringo right here this little
exploding one
then we're gonna see it being cast right
there
then we Dodge
all right let's get back speed more
powerful and more efficacious so it's
all about which type of player you feel
like you are and whether or not you want
to play with I want roast chicken or
with the Liberation and those are all
different options that is so cool
because like it like I see so much like
going on on the thing to so much
complexity and I I want to just try it I
think that's it right style works best I
mean I feel like it's the Dark Horse
that's it to be honest it feels like
much more powerful than just the dark
Hearts yeah and speaking of plants and
Potions we're going to be putting the
dark arts away there we go all right so
all right we're just two hours into the
stream not bad not bad
we're just two hours in
we did pretty good on that
all right let me get uh I'm gonna check
in with comments here get caught up a
little bit
and then we'll jump in I want to watch
the uh I wanna watch the no commentary
footage now
because I want you guys to hear
all of the sounds
sounds so much better
on the no combat or on the Note oh my
gosh the no commentary
and I know I still uh well I still owe
you all an impression we'll save that
for the end of the stream save that for
the end
Logan thank you for the Super Chat my
friend love the beanie retro hope you
had a great Christmas yes sir Logan yes
indeed yeah one of my Christmas gifts
here another one of my gifts right here
and then uh at one point on one of the
streams we'll have to bust out the
Weasley the Weasley sweater
or I mean I could just as easily say the
Retro sweater because it's got that got
the r on the front there
true Mr Moe like the beginning yeah
there's lots of uh we do the 10 minute
countdown then lots of hellos and
welcomes on the beginning indeed
nerdy giant with this
chat as well nerdy giant welcome
thank you for being here will this game
be more combat focused or more
exploration
I mean I feel like it's gonna be a
balance like so the what we were just
looking at tonight we're focused all on
the combat but in that most recent
gameplay showcase they showed off three
major sections of the game they showed
off your free roam like your open world
exploration they showed off combat and
then they showed off the uh like room of
requirement which is gonna have stuff
that a lot of us had no expectation for
whatsoever
amazing stuff that you could do in the
room of requirement in terms of raising
creatures and that sort of thing
so I mean I think
I
think
ideally when they set out I think they
would want it to be a balance of all of
those things
so I would say if you ask them I would
say they want it to be I mean obviously
with a game like this your main
encounters are gonna be they're gonna be
combat Centric right when you go through
but still I think the game will have a
ton of exploration if it doesn't
they they would be disappointed and I
feel like a lot of fans would be too I
mean just the castle alone there's going
to be so much to explore and find and do
Jesse with the Super Chat as well Jesse
how's it going welcome back good to see
you uh and thank you for the Super Chat
are you going to do a full walkthrough
when the game drops ooh a full walk
through
now that's something that I've never
done before like a full walkthrough like
a Let's Plays I've done several Let's
Plays a full walkthrough that's an
interesting idea
I will definitely have
all sorts of tip videos so
it's just like it's like time right
time
it's all about the time
as soon as I get to play the game
whenever that may be if we're able to
get an early copy we'll see
don't know what WB is doing on that
front like if they're gonna send out
early review copies or what if it only
goes to official industry folks I have
no idea
but that would obviously make a big
impact right if we could have a bunch of
con content prepared before the game
launches
ether says yes full walkthroughs and see
like full walkthroughs are also very uh
like lasting you know they're Evergreen
nerdy giant with another Super Chat hey
nerdy giant thank you very much again
winter ASMR in January or no I think for
sure yeah
I think for sure
they've done the other three I feel like
they have it ready to go it's just a
matter of of the timing and when they
want to do it
maybe New Year's Day a lot of people
have been thinking maybe New Year's Day
or maybe they wait till like a week
before the game you know and just to
give the fans like hey here's one more
you know look at a look at the winter
scenery from the game
I thought I put it on replay come on
loot playlist and shuffle playlist
I absolutely must
Ravenclaw Tyrell multiple screens of all
your streamers let's go
I Dustin I I really don't know because I
don't know how WB does things
like I feel like if it was up to
Avalanche I think for sure I think we
would get like early but sometimes they
don't really do too far in advance
and then it varies like how far in
advance like is it a week is it two days
is it a couple weeks a month
if it's a month I mean hey something
should be happening soon right
[Music]
winter ASMR video must include the last
music video shot I know right and my uh
I've got it as my wallpaper here
just gorgeous
just a gorgeous shot
hello perio or pyro welcome
deep needs more love yeah we know so
little about Deke
but I don't feel like we need to know
more right like I don't need a breakdown
on Deke I'm already intrigued enough
Jake with the Super Chat Jake my friend
thank you so much for the Super Chat God
Hogwarts Legacy deluxe edition
pre-ordered let's go dude congrats
[Music]
how did I snag that wallpaper
oh geez where is that posted
[Music]
anybody know anybody that can help Jay
Rossi out I can't remember where I
I maybe I did I just I might have just
screen grabbed it from the trailer
we need more info on Deke what I mean
I'd rather just wait and meet him in the
game
I don't want too many character details
revealed
like I feel like the the I feel like
they did a good job with poppy and
oh I can't remember what they said on
Sebastian's but in that size I almost
felt like Nat's eyes
was starting to reveal too much it
didn't
but I was like ah let's let's save a
little more of this you know
[Music]
wallpaper engine no no I mean just like
how you get the actual
[Music]
how you get that photo
oh I like that question nerdy giant
first hour of the game I think will be
we'll find out our our character's
backstory
how why we did not start off
at Hogwarts our first year I think that
will be answered within the first hour
some sort of event that we survive will
happen
probably through cut scenes maybe if
they surprised us there might be some
scenes we actually play
that was a big surprise I remember in
the lead up to the Last of Us
spoilers for The Last of Us if you
haven't played it by the way just for
the beginning of the game
um
all the preview stuff and everything
that people had seen nobody knew about
the beginning that that you start like
way before the outbreak happens
and so that was a was a really cool
moment when people first got that game
same thing they did the naughty dog did
the same thing with Uncharted 4. he
started that off like really really
a long time ago so I could see them
definitely starting off
maybe with a little playable section
give us some backstory on our character
our connection at least an introduction
to our connection to the ancient magic I
don't think they'll answer all of that
in the beginning but like why we why we
have this ancient magic right
how did it first manifest itself that
sort of thing
then I think we'll meet up with fig fig
will be sent to retrieve us maybe at the
request of the ministry
maybe the other guy that we see in the
carriage is also maybe that guy's
actually a Ministry official
clearly the ministry has us on their
radar and then I think James did a video
on this a long time ago I think he
pretty much nailed
the order of things at the beginning I
think that whole section at Gringotts
with fig is from the beginning of the
game but
it's it's not a guarantee but I think
it's likely from the beginning of the
game
I think we'll get our wand and all of
those sorts of things the robe
and then they'll have to be a tutorial
section somewhere let's see what would
be a good spot for the tutorial
dude it might actually be
it might actually be gring Gods we know
we already have our wand by then though
[Music]
maybe we just use like basic shots but
we know we should and see how much magic
does our character know at that point oh
so many questions
so many questions
and of course the Character Creator
right nerdy giant with another Super
Chat and the character creation we have
the tan cloak on in the state of play to
show off a few things exactly yeah yeah
that's what expecto go did a lot
breaking down yeah
yes indeed and I think that is why he
pieced a lot of that together is because
of what our character was wearing
although we've actually learned can
really wear what you want at any given
time according to Alan
but I still think he was pretty pretty
spot on with that
all right let's hop over to uh I want to
go
to some different footage now which I
think
let's see if I have this saved
I feel like I have so if you guys
haven't seen this IGN has some footage
from I feel like a lot of you have you
probably heard us talking about this but
the uh so this that we just watched the
Hogwarts Legacy gameplay showcase
IGN put up a bunch of the
yeah here they are
so this is just the battle arena scene
with no audio
or I'm sorry no commentary
oh man I'm gonna have to turn that up
hold on
you guys can probably barely hear it
right now
and I'm just gonna let some of this play
so if you're just joining in guys we
have discovered that a pug no
has either been totally removed from the
game or they have they have changed it
likely based on lore
so I didn't even I didn't even catch
this
and you know we we dig into this stuff
on a weekly basis nobody had ever
pointed this out to me in a stream until
tonight but we were talking about
how in this Allen says that R1
is an ancient magic throw
and I was like wait a second
that's a pug no
you've already said that's a pug no
so we went back look at the state of
play yep you can hear the character say
a pug no when R1 pops up on the barrel
but sure enough some folks in the chat
went through watched all of this
and said you don't hear them say it at
all so they have changed it it is no
longer an ancient magic throw
no longer an ancient magic throw
dude we got another Super Chat coming in
let's see nerdy giant again oh no that
was uh we had Jake though Jake right
after nerdy giant the last time God no I
read that one Jake I read that one yeah
I said that one out loud
all right so
let's watch this now common no
commentary
I wanna rewind it a bit so this first
guy I I just love getting to hear the
actual sounds of the game man
it's so cool
so you hear this first guy on the right
he says
how delightful then so this time our
character casts the verbal Avada cadaver
we hear it
[Music]
I think
wait
I don't think that's AK
I think that's but his petrificus
totalus green or maybe someone else is
casting patricus Hotel
hit Imperial here and then listen you
guys are gonna hear somebody yell pet
traffic
oh
I like it
hit me listen over here
so he breaks free after a bit from the
imperious curse you'll land suffer this
he says Jaybird says not AK yeah I think
I think that's definitely you hear them
petrifices
a lot of us thought it was AK we were
just looking at it earlier but because
it looks green
all right wave one done
I did it and the Nash wind at no less
such arrogance
okay right away this the
such arrogance from the goblin
wait what did that one say
oh I might need you guys help with this
one
something about like I survived this or
something
else
so yeah clearly not every time we cast a
spell do you hear the incantation
all right
so that time you hear them cast it
young friend you won't survive this my
young friend ah okay
nice job guys
wait what
are you doing
oh wait he's he is
I think he was uh is he imperialed
he's got the X
I guess that's why he wasn't attacking
all right that wave's done
notice no no pug no at all
oh whoa hold on we heard a lot of lines
right there but
the first one gets cut off
try not to
know
a Resto momentum first time that one was
confirmed so that is the hand
holding up right there
so no incantation it seems with the
ancient magic spell either
yeah we'll try subtitles I don't know if
it'll do anything in this one yeah
unavailable
I didn't think it would be available in
this one
now that time you hear him say it
and then they just cower in fear which
we're gonna read here before we wrap up
the stream uh Chandler confirmed that is
a like a side effect of a Vada cadaver
like you will people around it will
cower in fear
come on you
something about your outmatched surely
you can see that
you're terrible
you are terribly
what's going on
oh hold on what did that Goblin say
right there
oh
wow
the one that's sounding like this
oh wait did I skip I think I skipped too
much
one less human to worry about there you
go
dang you guys are good or you've already
done this once
oh man
you can hear a couple like over
like sound that they sound far away so
you can't quite make it out
oh
yeah
this is brutal
[Applause]
I'm not done with you right after the
protego
[Applause]
and then the big one with the story
implication right how dare you use that
spell so this ancient magic they are not
pleased the Goblins are not pleased when
we use it
what was this
we heard like a potion effect but I
don't see him drink anything
oh wait a second hold on did they use
one
oh they did
oh interesting so wait do we not is
there like not an actual animation
okay so our health is red about uh we're
very very low and then you see this go
from 10 to 9.
ten to nine
and they're just instant so I guess you
don't there's no like animation you
don't have to wait for it to
you know like Souls you gotta take out
the flask
all right now we're about to
trolls coming up I believe
not too many sound effects with Patrols
foreign
accio nothing happened on him
okay
yeah I wonder what you pressed somebody
said what did they press to heal up I
wonder what you pressed to use this this
one over here definitely L1 they may
have said what you
they may have said that in the last
showcase let's back up though and watch
this again very quickly so you hold L1
to pull this menu up then you release L1
to equip right here so you're gonna see
them the right stick here gonna flick
over to the right
now they've got that potion selected
which is the I think that's the focus
potion right the one that she called out
yep that's the focus potion
drink that so that when you do you do
get the animation for that and you get a
little effect but for whatever reason
this uh just this little
healing one you do not
man it definitely speeds up
all right so let's go all the way back
to when they used
so Vada Kedavra is pretty low right
there and we can get a look at sort of
how fast it's going right now
foreign
and then after they drink this though oh
my gosh I mean it just takes off
and it's ready wow
that's it right
oh
wait okay this is a different
ashwinder duelist over here she has
something to say
[Applause]
all right I need your help again chat
need your help again
[Applause]
oh my gosh man you guys are so good
oh I'm gonna enjoy this
[Applause]
and then reducto
[Applause]
just imagine when the actual game is out
you guys right
okay we hear that we hear it again
so he takes a little damage and yeah
just right away uses that green potion
gets back to full health
hold on she has something else to say
here
it just sounds like such
just sounds like nothing to me and then
as soon as you guys say it I'm like oh
yeah that's exactly
all right one more time one more time
okay I heard that one this is almost too
easy
ah yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
listen to this Goblin dude
right there at the end
squeeze
and
yeah
I'm not even trying anymore because you
guys are
I'm hearing all kinds of stuff and have
no idea what's actually been said
thank you
I'll call it out if I actually hear it
okay I heard somebody else say something
about using the spell
momentum
R2D2
when he gets launched
just so I I wasn't expecting that it's
so Random
this has become personal
I did just hear one say that
this has become personal let's hear him
again
[Music]
back
the chicken just like her rooster
just roaming around
Curio on that guy he helps us take the
other one out then we finish him
there we go
oh man
super interesting super interesting
all right guys well that was our combat
breakdown that was fun I got
really into that if you couldn't tell
I got way into that and discovered a few
things I did not know before let me turn
the volume back down so it's not
too loud for you guys
[Music]
oh
all right I owe you guys an impression
here
so when we get to 100 likes in the
Stream
for any newcomers out there we do a
random bit of Harry Potter quote trivia
and then we when we get to 200 I never
agreed to this but chat says I did so
I'm kidding I'm kidding we get to 200 we
do a random impression from the Harry
Potter series so
let's see last time we did Dobby
[Music]
and I can't even remember who we did the
first time mod say yeah right that's
what oh and the mods I'm overruled so
I chose my mods for a reason I trust my
mods
this is what happened last time when I
I'm kidding guys are kidding go Ninja's
like you did you did
300 to a cartwheel see my setup
unfortunately we can't like this wall I
don't know how it looks on stream
does it look pretty close to me because
it's like right here like I can reach
out and touch this wall
so I don't have any room to do a whole
lot of
like anything physical related you know
like James has got the purits
I don't think I would have room for
anything like that
or you guys couldn't see my whole body
you would you would just see like
you would just see like legs or
something go flying by
okay so here we we always get so many
good suggestions and then I'm like oh
oh that one's good oh that one's good
too that one's good as well
all right we got Umbridge or Harry's
Aunt we got a Bellatrix
yeah it's not even the camera it's just
like not enough physical space back here
because we could zoom the camera out
like let me show you guys what that
looks like if we uh
let's see where are you like if we
zoomed the camera out
yeah I mean see so that's as far out as
I can zoom right there
now we could move it like
[Music]
there you go look into my
there you go get a nice desk view here
view of the coke of the Coke Zero
man let's see how up I can take this
thing oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've never never been able to show this
on stream
why have I not done this before
check this out here's where the here's
where the hammer is guys
here's where the hammer is
right there
and then below it we've got
old school game Heap controller couple
hats couple Metroid items
and then when I when it's not like the
Christmas season I have this
this is blue in the shape of an R
right here
[Music]
Roger about as small as mine itty bitty
living space no it's like I have my room
set up in a very interesting way
so like
in front of me like the the other side
of the room is actually bigger so I'm in
like an office
but on the other side of the room I have
like a small little
like love seat and a a TV that's where
my kids are always gaming
so I I've rearranged this room so many
times but then this one I finally got is
like my this is like my setup I could
rearrange it
but I don't know I just want to like
slowly decorate This and like get more
stuff
either up here or here
for a nice little background
all right let's see we need a quote here
we need a quote
[Music]
the greatest one ever made Thor's hammer
[Music]
oh that would be a fun Bellatrix one
[Music]
I always just like
I wait for one to really
oh I like this one I like this one
Hannah all right Hannah's the winner
tonight
Hannah is the winner
okay let's see so Hannah says uh one
from gilderoid Lockhart and even gave me
the quote so you guys gotta You Gotta
Give me the quote too so then as soon as
I hear it as I read it I can hear it in
my head
all right
hold on hold on
Fame is a Fickle friend Harry
celebrity is as celebrity does
remember that
Kenny wall hear me
wait what does he say what does he say
when he's in the uh
when he gets into the classroom
can you all see me
can you all
hear me
Good Old Lockhart
[Music]
like The Wider The Wider Zoom when it
zoomed out a little bit more
foreign
hey have a good one volte thanks for
stopping by
[Music]
10 out of 10 says Roger
uh I do I do my best they're not all
gonna be 10 out of tens
we I feel like we got we've gotten a lot
of Bella tricks suggestions though I
think we need to do a Bellatrix one next
time she gets really like
she's got just like that I don't know
that sadistic you can just hear it in
her voice
you can hear it in her voice
all right you guys were saying you like
The Wider view I want to I want to
experiment with this again now
all right so if we Zoom all the way out
it would be more like this
okay so here's how I normally have it
this is like my
position one
so yeah it gets a little bit wider I
feel like I'd wanna
angle it down maybe a little bit
[Music]
just a wee little bit
[Music]
that is a good one Owen
[Music]
do you live here
do you live here
all right so let's see what do we have
over the next couple weeks guys how many
streams do we have left
[Music]
I've recently been taking a look so
December's done you guys this is
officially our last stream of December
the next time I talk to you guys
on a live stream we will be in the year
of Hogwarts Legacy
in the year 2023
all right so we'll have a stream on
Tuesday the third the 10th so one two
three four five we are down to five
streams left people
five streams left
oh my goodness that like that puts it
into perspective right
that puts it into perspective man
look at that dude
the third the 10th the 17th the 24th the
31st and then the next week we will be
playing Hogwarts Legacy
wow wow it's crazy man
[Music]
no stream February 7th oh man
I think we'll do February 6th we gotta
do like some big countdown
so Nico has been wanting me for a while
Nico has had this idea of a stream of me
going through and watching my old all of
my old Hogwarts videos
and I can't think of a better time for
that than like the night before the game
launches
oh we got a lot of videos we might have
to get started pretty early
we would have to get started very early
[Music]
Ravenclaw Tyrell was hoping you would do
that too I think that'd be so fun Nico
thinks I've been ignoring him but no
I've heard Nico I've heard you
I've just been saving it for just wait
do I have this on like fast speed hold
on
[Music]
it seemed like it was going really fast
gone back through a lot of prediction
wins fun looking back indeed
seeing how many things we thought we
were going to happen that did
I wonder if you can figure out which one
you started watching on that would be a
fun idea Mr Moe people could be like oh
this is where I came on board
I've went back and updated
the vast majority of people will have
never seen any of this but I I did go
back through and I updated a lot of old
thumbnails to look more like our newer
thumbnails that we use because for a
while I was just like you know totally
trying to figure things out so I used a
bunch of different types of thumbnails
for the record he ghosts me I need that
out there
no I'm usually talking to Nico like
after stream it's like 1am for me
and then I just fall asleep
but no I've I think that's such a good
idea
yeah moonly I think it would be it would
have to be like February 6th right
and then we would count down to the to
the actual release
that's sort of what I'm picturing in my
head right now
who the heck knows dude we may have to
do like a 24 hour
I may just have to go all out dude go
crazy
[Music]
could you imagine man
like start around
gosh if we started at like
[Music]
well probably start around our normal
time
like start about 8 P.M
go all through the night go all the way
up to midnight when the game when the
game hits
so we would have to we'd have to have
something to do for four hours I wonder
if that I honestly like the fact that
I'm questioning is that enough time to
get through all my videos
the way that we stop and talk about
things probably not probably not
all right I gotta take a peek now hold
on
just before we Hop Off
[Music]
I gotta take a peek
all right so let's see how far back we
have to scroll dude
how far back do we have to scroll
to look at this crazy history I'm not
gonna count them all
I'm just gonna we could probably count
them by looking at the playlists but
I recently I split the playlists as well
because they were they were just getting
too big
all right so right here
two years ago oh my gosh man
this was on
October 2nd 2020 was our first Hogwarts
Legacy video
that is insane man
if we're getting ready to enter 2023
energy is energy is gonna be insane
but like see if I did that I feel like
people everybody would stop watching as
soon as we hit
um
as soon as we hit
midnight I feel like people would stop
watching
and then I would be like streaming to
nobody
that is just crazy October 2nd 2020.
all right so then
like you can see man I was just like I
was trying so many different I made a
lot of animal crossing videos
and then I was like you know what let's
let's I'm into Harry Potter love Harry
Potter
look at this dude look at this
Super Mario these like let's plays 120
views
does Super Mario 64 still hold up in
2020 443 views
Animal Crossing 1300 views and then here
we go man here we go the Hogwarts Legacy
hype 16k
gameplay features we need 47k I'm like
okay yo
yo there may be something to this spells
you want in Hogwarts Legacy
I'd love to see these spells see like
some of these I guarantee a lot of you
especially more recent folks there's a
lot of these you guys probably haven't
seen
spells I'd love to see
oh yeah this is a fun animal crossing
video I made uh there were some Harry
Potter designs in Animal Crossing
every magical creature confirmed
then we had morality system so yeah this
was like just a completely different
thumbnail Style
Hogwarts Legacy morality system
confirmed interesting they've now said
there is no virality system
oh
oh man
oh wait hold on what do we need to
revisit Nico
put on a Luigi's Mansion video I need it
dude I still think those Luigi's Mansion
videos were good videos
I spent a lot of time editing those man
these right here yeah yeah
hold on
Chad's gonna be like okay we're out
watch this dude watch this
[Laughter]
okay yeah I would cut that out now
Splash intro screens they're done all
right so if you remember
the last time we left off uh our buddy
Professor egad who's really kind of a
jerk they're just not fast-paced enough
probably
I mean he he he really is uh I mean I
guess you could say he's one of those
stereotypical scientists who doesn't
really care about look see completely
different room set up too
completely different room that was when
I was on the other side of the room so
this wall that you guys are seeing right
now is like where this this white thing
is
oh my gosh man dude Nico Nico has been
here for a while my friends
all right so hold on then we did
everything we know that was the first
Hogwarts Legacy why did I think they
were confirmed a recent Gamespot
Instagram post has caught the attention
of fans over on the Harry Potter game
subreddit has it retro all the details
for you here in today's video so guys
after digging into this it seems that
Warner Brothers has indeed confirmed
it's a bit more natural now Hogwarts
Legacy via a slightly updated official q
a this is the Q a on the Hogwarts Legacy
I feel like this was confirmed picked up
by the Gamespot Instagram account come
on Metro get to the news dude you're
taking too long we're 30 seconds in also
take a look at the full FAQ to see oh my
gosh
my voice sounds I feel like sounds the
same but I get it I get into it way
faster now other details we can confirm
and we're starting right now oh you
should have started 30 seconds ago retro
Records who are here if we're meeting
for the first time no dad who loves
games and the stories I know some of you
love the intros videos every week here
on YouTube and also stream over on
Twitch also not anymore I have a ton of
Hogwarts Legacy content on the channel
that's true to a playlist at the end
dude oh my gosh no wonder people did
watch these I was a minute where you can
see our full coverage for the I should
just roast my own videos it's just kind
of what I'm doing anyway
kind of what I'm doing anyway but listen
to this dude yeah Dark Lord I love those
games man I'm gonna have to go watch I
don't think I finished I did I
definitely finished the game but I don't
think I finished out the series because
no nobody was watching so I'm like okay
I'm done recording these
oh my gosh I've gotten so much better
like I'm a minute in the game the devs
at Avalanche software officially
unveiled Hogwarts Legacy at the PS5
Showcase Event back in September and
things have been mostly pretty quiet as
far as updates go oh my gosh at least
until now for me it started when I came
across this Reddit post with the title
there's the news Instagram okay we made
this Legacy will have a morality system
to the official Gamespot Instagram which
does indeed confirm this the Instagram
post reads as follows Warner Brothers
explained at their recent q a session
regarding Hogwarts Legacy that the game
what a morality system I forgot about
this players will also encounter
missions and scenarios that will
challenge their morale
so the Gamespot just get it wrong or did
they change this quality and determine
what they stand for close quote my first
thought after reading this was okay what
recent q a session
as far as I'm aware there haven't been
any recent events or official statements
from Warner Brothers or Avalanche that's
right that game spot is they're actually
referencing the official FAQ on the
Hogwarts website I went there to confirm
this and I'm talking too slow I'm gonna
put I'm gonna speed myself up I watch
all my videos at 2X
actually let's try let's try like 1.5 I
found the quote used in their Instagram
post but there's a Rio the full quote
has more information that you may or may
not have known already depending on when
you last check the website it reads how
do you play Hogwarts Legacy and then
they go on with the answer here Hogwarts
Legacy is filled with immersive mashed
by yourself
they take forever they will grow their
characters abilities as they match take
forever getting into combat skills and
select companions to help them face off
against deadly enemies players will also
encounter missions and scenarios that
will pose difficult choices and
determine what they stand for so this is
exciting for a few reasons first off it
doesn't because like yes my plan is
coming together we're starting early
though I was supposed to save this for
the uh like the night before stream this
would be this one this is it dude this
is what we're doing man
I could totally see like we could
definitely spend four hours doing this
we get a hundred percent spend four
hours Blue Moon with the Super Chat blue
moon thank you so much for your support
can't wait for the upcoming retro
bashing on retro special to celebrate
the new year
oh right
man it is crazy like how much better you
get pretty strongly about but it's good
to have it confirmed here the wording is
particularly interesting though because
they call out but like um scenarios as
it relates to player choice there's
there was like there was a definitely an
interesting video here but the way I
presented it I'm just so this makes it
even more probable that our choices are
going to have real in-game consequences
maybe even diverging story paths but
it's natural while poor key games are
not direct all right I'm done I can't do
it anymore we'll do it more later but
yeah for those of you who just uh hopped
on board recently so apparently I was
wrong about this or I should say
Gamespot was wrong
about it being confirmed uh oh this was
when my first this was my first big
Theory one still one of my favorite
videos so the whole thing about huge uh
creatures this was just based off the
first
he didn't even have the uh state of play
stuff yet this was just the first reveal
trailer November 17 2020.
I was like all right people we need to
be paying attention to the creatures
need to be paying attention to these
dudes with the skull masks they might be
poachers
magical beasts you want like 13k views
21k views I mean so you can already see
like the views we're starting to pick up
right away
oh my gosh why did this video only get
251 views
I put a lot of time into that
hey if you want to get started in uh
YouTube guys I still stand by what I
include here
new leaks
oh and then here we had the
the new release Window Man
what's like the first one that really
blows up
let's see here
I mean all these are kind of hovering
around
15K 13k
and then we had several animal crossing
videos did really well too
oh that was the first one that really
took off
that one right there
this uh I think this guy worked on the
music for Hogwarts Legacy
and he shared some stuff that really
just like how excited they were to be
working on the game I don't think there
were too many new things in there
and then this was the big one this was
the big one
35 Hogwarts Legacy facts we know for
sure a year ago on that
all right Nico I'm sold dude I'm sold
we've got our plans for February 6th
we've got our plans
Oh wrong one let's see oh there's all
you guys though hello chat
all right let's see
let's pull up some music here as we as
we close out things
[Music]
wait what are you guys talking about
retweet hold up hold up hold up
hold up
foreign
is going to be good after the first few
videos right exactly
how old is the Headmaster of the school
oh you guys are you guys are back on the
uh what Chris is gonna Name the
character the uh creatures
[Music]
thank you
thanks to Potter Legacy Again by the way
[Music]
I heard of Hogwarts tickets commercial
at the doctor's office today
he was behind me but my head heard all
the audio did see the actual Commercial
Cool to Findlay here we are close now
[Music]
just popped up on my PlayStation app
foreign
interesting right here I don't know this
person or how to verify this already
make and plan some of it's an
advertisement for it one of the biggest
German twitch streamers got invited to
go on January 6th to play exclusively
interesting
[Music]
didn't even know they did game
commercials on TV what
at the cinema today oh Maddie I don't
know if that was Maddie hanging out in
the Stream somebody else said they uh
saw it and sent them as well
[Music]
what Dr sherbet
oh my gosh the music is I forgot to turn
it back down
because we had to turn it up for the uh
whole videos
don't yell at me Dr sherbet I don't like
it when people yell at me
it gets it gets me all nervous
Mr well I was jamming
guys don't yell I get nervous and people
yell calm down
it's all good though
oh man all right well yep guys five more
streams left five more live streams left
before the launch of Hogwarts Legacy
we just we just got our plans
we just got our plans for the night
before leading up I'm not confirming a
24-hour stream yet but
I don't know man I can't stay up that
late like I used to I feel like I could
go five six a.m easy but 12 I mean 24
hours dude that'd be tough maybe a 12
hour though maybe a 12 hour
we'll have to see ma'am we'll have to
see
but definitely like a countdown stream
for sure definitely a countdown stream
leading up to the launch of the game
oh yeah shrewd true uh Draco yeah if we
count the
yeah so but only like only like five
more of these types of
chill hangout you know speculate kind of
streams
the the day before I mean essentially
the day of if we're waiting till
midnight man things will just be so
hyped
things will be so hyped 48-hour stream
oh my gosh has anyone ever done that's
crazy
that's what you're just talking about
Jason yeah that's what we were just
talking about definitely a countdown
stream of me and leading up to midnight
me playing the game
I feel like I could at least go 12 hours
feel like I could at least go 12 hours I
don't know about 24 though
at least 12.
and then you know the rest of the week I
gotta think about it man I gotta think
about it
because like YouTube is really like I
want to be very careful with the
algorithm
when it comes to the launch of the game
and I don't feel like live streaming
would hurt it in any way but I also
wonder if there's an opportunity to do
some stuff with the live stream on
Twitch
and then like have the video the YouTube
continue to be our hangout for you know
like the theories and speculation and
stuff
so yeah I gotta think about it
but definitely I mean there's good
there's gonna be gameplay of me
you watched if you did 48 hours oh my
goodness that's crazy
wait another three hours to play why
would you have why would you have to
wait another three hours Jenny I think
it should be
it don't don't games normally have it to
where like if you're on West Coast you
get to play at nine Eastern
I thought they changed that recently
and by recently I mean like in the past
five five six years or so
because they used to do it where they
would um
wait that changed
don't get too tired right before the
game I know right
so that's why I would have to be I'm
already off the Monday Tuesday Wednesday
for sure
getting it at 11 Central Jaybird yeah I
think that's how it works like so East
Coast eastern time would be
midnight for people on East then you go
to Central Time which would be 11 when
you get to play it and then you know as
you move out to the West Coast 10 and
then nine for the uh the West Coast
folks
[Music]
yeah that's kind of insane Draco that's
kind of insane
all right guys it's been fun man thank
you all so much for the love and support
I had a blast as we always do as we
always do
um working on a video actually right now
probably gonna be hitting the channel on
Thursday it's gonna be our exploration
breakdown give you guys a little sneak
peek a lot of the stuff we talked about
on last week's stream you know we're all
over the place when we stream three hour
stream I'm gonna condense down into
about a 10 minute video for everybody
um so look forward to that and then I'm
definitely going to do one on combat as
well so I know we wanted to do a poll
question tonight and I forgot never got
around to it
um but check out the Discord exclamation
point Discord we have a section in there
for suggestions so if you guys have any
video ideas I mean we got five weeks
guys six weeks till to launch of the
game if there's any any video any fun
speculation anything you want that you'd
like to see on the channel before the
game comes out let me know let me know
because once I mean once the game's out
like everything changes right Everything
Changes
thank you Nico thank you
indeed Wizarding Wednesday I think James
for the holidays but I believe he is uh
I think he'll be on tomorrow I think he
will
I'll see a bunch of you in the chat
there most likely if he is uh live
streaming
all right guys thank you all so much I
hope you all have a fantastic rest of
your week and a wonderful New Year's
everybody be safe have a good time and
I'll see you guys in 2023
thank you all so much for being here
have a good one guys
foreign